[Music]
holy Shh
I know welcome to [ __ ] fat man on
Westeros welcome to fat man be on I'm
Kevin Smith hi I'm Mark Barnard
everybody coming to you live from the
[ __ ] Seven Kingdoms it's been a
minute oh my god you go away for like
four months and they change everything
no doubt man it feels like I've been
away as long as Game of Thrones was off
the air and [ __ ] before we do anything
else did you watch I did and I feel as
if we are now in the in the time when I
was so close to the weepy tree where
like I'm just excited to see people who
haven't seen people in a while where's
it's like John and like Aria it's like
hey how you doing I'm not dead either
right [ __ ] nuts right like it was
that whole hour was a little like are
you [ __ ] dead like gonna live like
I'll shoot me too like there was a lot
it was a lot of table-setting
it was lots of lots of moving pieces but
to be fair there was a big [ __ ] piece
of information that was provided to a
character that would have been [ __ ]
huge if we were all learning it too but
we all have known it for 18 years and
[ __ ] and so when they [ __ ] rock him
with it and he's like no no like yes
[ __ ] move on [ __ ] us we know this
[ __ ] here come the walkers of jail it
was it was but it was fun to sit back
and watch I got in like a fight with my
wife over and [ __ ] she was trying to
chat to me and I was like shut this
hasn't been on in two [ __ ] years shut
up alright God you've had two years to
ask me anything now but it was yeah man
I'm glad he's back how many episodes six
I think so six more in addition to what
we just won't know just six total that
was one of the six yep hurry to [ __ ] up
no walkers man
if there were white runners we'd be
already there it's nice that JC first
off for those at home playing along and
whatnot we are here live at our home at
the scum and villainy Cantina in
Hollywood and Hollywood Boulevard your
hands together ladies and gentlemen nice
to be home generally the place is very
Star Wars II but right now of course
it's Game of Thrones even stuff like
that but it's going back I mean number
one when I saw this I want [ __ ] ape
[ __ ] I was like you need to do this all
the [ __ ] time to JC I was like just
every week make it something else and
it's like we'd go broke I'm like all
right maybe not every week but but I I
feel like it's something like the you
know the base of course is always gonna
be the Cantina but like you reskin this
[ __ ] oh yeah anything for any
[ __ ] event like [ __ ] you know it's
too soon to do Avengers because that's
happening in a minute but what's the
next big geek movie coming down the pike
I mean it's Avengers it's John wick it's
well John wick if you theme the place of
John wick it's just everybody killing
puppies left and right and [ __ ] until a
Keano look-alike comes in all mad and
[ __ ] fights people fast and it's far
from home right it's spider-man far from
home isn't far from home next
Joker also so you could do Gotham City
or from afar from home though it's him
in Europe right yeah it's like we would
just be doing Europe it's just this
without the blood pretty much but but
you could if you get away with Gotham
City this place could totally be Gotham
City totally and then you know what I
was gonna say and then there's a Star
Wars movie coming but it's always
[ __ ] Star Wars it here I really
thought I was onto something for a
second there was a collie she's like I'm
2 years a dia [ __ ] but it looks
awesome if you have not been here before
it's a great time to come here unless
you're [ __ ] like there JC said the
first night they Game of Thrones did two
people showed up dressed as like ahsoka
and and Ben Kenobi and they were just
like oh man they took that away from us
- yeah [ __ ] winter came she but yeah if
you're a remotely a Game of Thrones fan
it's definitely a sight to behold man
you're seeing like one angle and the
tree which is [ __ ] unnerving enough
and [ __ ] but if you look around the room
they did kind of turn it into the
Targaryen critters and [ __ ] yeah that's
kind of cool all right it's been a
minute
yes since we've done this and the reason
was because mark and I got into a fight
now I went off to make a movie and I got
done making the movie and what's weird
is when I look around the bar there are
a lot of folks that went to the movie
mod squad and so like I keep seeing you
[ __ ] people every day as I cut the
movie over and over again stuff so I
figured when I set aside the editing to
come here I was like you know what I'll
take a break man it's nice to interact
with the world and see different faces
same [ __ ] faces all over again
but yeah it's I went off mate Affleck
had a [ __ ] blast it was it was weird
I was not prepared for it this is a
story I've been telling everybody but I
haven't told it publicly but everybody
in my life everybody's like how's the
movie I'm like shut the [ __ ] down I
wasn't ready
and I had two [ __ ] years and change
to get ready so I figured I was ready
and [ __ ] but be honest with you man I
got [ __ ] soft because I've been
working on them CW shows and you know
when you're on Supergirl and flash it's
like you can't fail like they they make
that show with or without you I'm pretty
sure I fell asleep for three days and
they still kept making the [ __ ] show
what I failed to factor in - Jay and
Silent Bob reboot was that I have not
been in a movie since why me I did a day
on yoga hosers right when I dress up
like a [ __ ] sausage but I haven't
been in
movie for a prolonged period of time one
of mine since clerks - which is 2006 and
I was only in 20% of that movie I
haven't been the co-lead of a movie
since 2001 when I was a young man and
vibrant this was I was that was the
thing I was unprepared for like suddenly
we got to set and I was used to like oh
you know I'll [ __ ] me ride monitor or
not you know like it'll be fun I was
looking for the good time that I have on
every other show didn't have it on this
not that it was a hellish time but there
was no time for a good time because it's
like being the scene when the scene is
over go watch the scene with it you
might have to go again so go back and do
the scene again then if I could come
back and then watch the scene and then
okay we're [ __ ] behind already we got
to go to the next scene and [ __ ] we shot
in 21 days which was a ridiculous
schedule but that was the bridge that's
the only way the movie was gonna get
made but to give you some sort of
context we shot clerks in 21 days that's
my first movie shot in black and white
in one [ __ ] location so this movie
which is a road movie that takes place
from New Jersey to California and has a
different cast member joining in almost
every scene it's like the dirty Muppet
movie you just keep [ __ ] seeing
cameos and [ __ ] like that but movie was
dirty enough pretty pretty much totally
so many hands up asses dude yes and we
all know what the Rainbow Connection
really meant so it's it was just kind of
like I wasn't prepared I wasn't I didn't
I forgot how much it kind of takes a TIA
in the 21 days you know there was just
no time no time to like really enjoy it
and not that it was unenjoyable like of
what I remember of it was like wow that
was beautiful there were moments pockets
where I was like oh my god that was so
[ __ ] wonderful and then it passed and
we were on to the next thing there were
sequences in the movie that you know I
had this script for two [ __ ] years I
was tinkering it with it for two years I
did 12 [ __ ] drafts I think by the
time we shot so I knew this [ __ ] like
inside and [ __ ] it out and newer scenes
I could not [ __ ] wait to shoot
because they were gonna be so fun and
they came and happened
and like I didn't even have time to
enjoy them I just had time to [ __ ]
make sure that we got everything we
needed before we [ __ ] moved on so you
know a lot of people I'm not complaining
it's you know it's I got to make the
movie I wanted to make if I if I guess
what I'm saying is I did
there's no time to smoke as much weed as
I normally do that's what I was really
looking forward to like this movie's
gonna be a walk down memory lane I'm
gonna be blazed every [ __ ] moment and
it's gonna be like I figured the movies
kind of like remember Bob Fosse made all
that jazz this is kind of like my all
that jazz so I was like I want to be
[ __ ] blazed throughout it cuz I'm
gonna be meeting everybody I ever met in
my entire life like the last 10 minutes
a big fish and [ __ ] and then I
couldn't I couldn't get I couldn't be
blade there was like no time to smoke
like to you know like I need five
minutes to smoke this cigarette they're
like you're on [ __ ] time
so I'd smoke in the morning before I
left the house and that pretty much had
to last me until like lunch wait holding
your breath
pretty much man like the whole [ __ ]
day I might as well burn underwater and
[ __ ] and then I'd smoke again and then I
had to carry me through to [ __ ]
dinner time I realized these are first
world problems a kid but but yeah it was
it was weird I wasn't prepared for that
element of life I guess what I'm saying
is like who knew it was a job like you
had to work like there's some work
involved in directing and [ __ ] I forgot
so only if you're in it though that's
the thing I'll never forget him do that
again at least not for another 18
[ __ ] years like if we ever did
another ask universe flick it wouldn't
be like Jay and Silent Bob it would be
like you know [ __ ] mall rats and
featuring Jay and Silent Bob like in a
little role in [ __ ] as much screen time
as we had like if you if you're familiar
with strike back there were moments at
Jay and Silent Bob strike back where we
went away from Jay and Silent Bob so
like you'd go hang out with Will Ferrell
you'd go hang out with the girl gang and
we were in in those scenes Jay and I I
didn't realize this until we were on set
but the director was so mad at the
writer the writer put us into literally
every [ __ ] scene there's not a single
scene we're not in man and that's cuz
the writer was [ __ ] stoned when he
wrote it
and he wasn't thinking about the
director at all he's like there's gonna
be amazing and [ __ ] and the director got
there the director is also the actor and
the editor and and he was like wait a
sec I can't do all this [ __ ] and [ __ ]
the writers like [ __ ] you figure it out
[Laughter]
so it was yeah it was very strange man
so yeah I did warned up in it like every
[ __ ] scene of the movie and this is
the thing that I learned on this movie
I'm sorry 420 this is the thing I
learned about on this movie that I'd
never gone through on any other [ __ ]
movie I've ever done in my life
post heart attack I went vegan lost some
weight and [ __ ]
so sauna Bob this time around doesn't
look like he's ever looked in the movies
before I watched strike back right
before we went and I was like oh my god
like [ __ ] I better [ __ ] get some
CG and put on some weight cuz I don't
even look like the same [ __ ]
character anymore in [ __ ] and I was like
Pablo get used to it so I'm sitting
there [ __ ] looking at it one not [ __ ]
I just hit a pothole what was the point
of this story I'm not sure man I was
just riding with you goddamn it was
[ __ ] good yeah [ __ ] what a pothole
I just hit and fell into it what was it
yes thank you
[ __ ] well done man that's all you
[ __ ] needed yes my pen Sid brought it
right back
now Dumbledore's ready to go so I look
different and and because I look
different I cared in a way that I've
never cared before so you know we shoot
a take and then I'm in the take so that
I have to go watch the take after we
shoot it to see if we got it and there
were more than one it happened a few
times well I watched the take and I was
just like we should go again I don't
look as good as I could and we went and
[ __ ] we wouldn't act it again just so
that I the guy was no dialogue could sit
there Miller
we'll go again Kevin needs of vanity
take yeah well everybody back to one I
never had that problem before I like the
van and like if you ask anyone who
worked on this play out in the picture
like hair was a big issue because right
before we went
I watched Jay and Silent Bob strike back
and like nobody gave a [ __ ] about our
hair continuity and so our hairs all
over the place we look like ratty meth
heads and [ __ ] like that so this time
around I said look I don't care what
we're doing if we're in the middle of a
take man
if the [ __ ] hair goes Wiggy just come
in and fix it like break the tick I
don't give a [ __ ] like [ __ ] because
I'm the editor and the editor hates that
[ __ ] messy hair [ __ ] so like don't
worry you'll know you might piss off the
director a little bit the [ __ ] in the
editors in charge so come on in and fix
the hair way and so that started on day
one for 21 days we'd be in the middle of
takes and it was no-fault the hair
department god bless him they were so
[ __ ] on top of it like we'd be
sitting there acting our [ __ ] asses
off and suddenly they'd come in and
[ __ ] fix our hair and Jason Mewes
would always look at me and be like you
piece [ __ ] and I was like you're gonna
[ __ ] thank me man
so it was it was nuts man we we at one
point in the movie like you know I
wanted that I wanted the hair kind of
fixed and [ __ ] but like at the same time
it was like time consumed every time it
happened you'd hear like the [ __ ]
whole crew go oh like let out a groan
and [ __ ] so I was just like look if we
ever [ __ ] do this again the sequel is
gonna be called Jay and Silent Bob get
crew cuts and [ __ ] we're gonna do
that in the first scene and then [ __ ] it
doesn't matter what happens after that
there was like a real [ __ ] issue man
it was strange going back into the world
it was delightful it was [ __ ]
wonderful it was very much like the last
10 minutes a big fish I saw a [ __ ]
everybody I ever loved and worked with
and whatnot it was really [ __ ]
magical and then I got home and started
well I mean I was cutting while we were
shooting the movie I got home and kind
of cut it to form and now I'm bringing
it down chipping away and stuff I had a
little screening at the house last night
with some friends which was really
[ __ ] illuminating where I was like oh
[ __ ] I can lose this you know you said
they're going like this is they'll never
understand the [ __ ] movie without
this
and then you show it to people and that
you don't need that and you're so happy
to let it go because they bring the time
down I I said that like hey the first
cut was one hour and fifty minutes and
now I'm gonna try to get it down to 145
because that's what Jay and Silent Bob
strike back was and some cats online
we're like don't why the [ __ ] are you
cutting it like joke we want to see
every [ __ ] minute [ __ ] and like no
you don't like you think you do you
think you do but it's like just me like
I'm [ __ ] I'm like I'm doing your films
getting rid of air I'm not getting rid
of anything cool like it's weird I said
maybe cuz cuz I'm a STONER but like the
movie just reveals itself it just tells
you like what wants to go away and the
more you sit there and spend time with
it it's just like you know this is
unnecessary like you're just holding
onto this for sentimentality or [ __ ]
like that so things like start falling
away so far I've been able to maintain
the entire cast that's always good news
everybody who came out to play but I'm
chipping away at the time and the
tighter it gets the more it starts to
resemble the movie if that makes sense
now we're coming to a place where I'm
gonna lose interest because I'm only in
this to see the movie and once I see the
movie I'm like oh that's what it looks
like and then I move on to the next
thing so the window is closing between
me and the flick because we're on a very
accelerated post schedule so I'm I don't
get to spend as much time as I would
like with the flick and whatnot but
that's okay cuz we're almost to the
point where I'm ready to let it go by
virtue of the fact that I'm like that's
now there'll be bells and whistles like
a better sound mix and some visual
effects and [ __ ] like that
but it's pretty damn watchable you can
watch with Mandan and get the whole
[ __ ] gist of it and stuff go on a
really enjoyable if I can ride a warm
ride funniest [ __ ] but it's the movie is
incredibly oddly for Jay and Silent Bob
movie oddly emotional and maybe that's I
say that because I was one of the guys
but like it's it's you know I remember
where after the heart attack
some people said I can't [ __ ] wait to
see what movie he makes next because
it's going to be informed by his
near-death experience and I was like no
it's not like
the next movies James I'm Bob reboot
like Fagin oh my god they're gonna be so
disappointed but it did wind up being
informed by the heart attack like in as
much as like everybody came back to be
like because the heart attack like every
cast member who came down to shoot with
us all the cameos and [ __ ] when they
were done they would be like I'm glad
you're alive
and then they'd [ __ ] leave and [ __ ]
and I was like Oh buggin they're all
happy I'm here like I just have a very
guilty gasp you know like this [ __ ]
almost died so it informed it in that
way but it also informed it in in other
ways man it's it's a weird like
wonderful movie but I still like him
compelled to get it down my wife watches
a bunch of [ __ ] programming and she
lives on [ __ ] let Netflix and
streaming stuff so she's like your
[ __ ] head is still in the 90s where
you got to cut something down because
like they need an extra running time or
some says [ __ ] but she's like [ __ ]
gonna live like in the streaming world
forever she's like don't break your neck
[ __ ] trying to take the time down but
I'm like that's not how it works it's
not cuz oh they give you more time I'll
take up all the [ __ ] time it's like
as the storyteller you just want it to
be this [ __ ] tight drum like I
remember somebody when I said oh it's um
150 I'm gonna try to get it down
somebody was like don't you you know I
saw a cut [ __ ] from Jay and Silent Bob
strike back and you should have left
that [ __ ] in there was a scene with
hookers that was really funny and [ __ ]
and I'm like great you saw it and you
thought it was funny but it's like that
didn't help the narrative it's not like
what's gonna happen if they don't meet
those hookers like you know like at a
certain point like the story lets go of
the elements that aren't needed to tell
the story and yeah like you got there's
lots of funny there and stuff but like
some [ __ ] that's just funny for the sake
of funny that's not moving things
forward
you know you'll see on the extras or
something like that but it doesn't feel
like it needs to be part of the story
fascinating [ __ ] process and I've
edited [ __ ] like since you know I don't
know I've always added [ __ ] when I'm on
the CW shows they have an editor that
you work with but I always added my own
[ __ ] but I ought to have an edited abuse
universe movie in a while
and it's a completely different
experience that was I think what really
kind of slowed the process down through
our production
I cannot remember caring more about like
anything I've ever made in my entire
life and that includes the [ __ ] ones
that like when I was a kid I used to do
this [ __ ] like it would save the [ __ ]
universe man like oh my god we're gonna
tell the [ __ ] truth with this alright
we're gonna make [ __ ] people laugh
and it's gonna heal it's gonna forget
like you know just we were in our 20s so
so I treated them all seriously and
that's why they played away they do and
sometimes connect the way they do but
this one I was it just meant like the
world this one was like holy it honestly
felt like once this is done you are
gonna [ __ ] die so get it right and
and the heart attack inform that to
where I'm like I'll [ __ ] like you'd
go at any second [ __ ] so I was like get
it right because this has to say
everything about who you ever were like
as an artist as an entertainer as
[ __ ] Bob Silent Bob as [ __ ] and if
it's sums up 25 years of my life as a
creative entity and then it also
includes the 23 years prior to that
like [ __ ] everything that led up to
it it's just weird walk through my head
and heart and stuff so I was so [ __ ]
up the ass of the movie like I had as
much as I was working all the time I'm
sure I Jason had a tough time of it from
day to day because I would be like like
you know he'd be snootch I'd be like no
[ __ ] snootch like this is [ __ ]
serious and he'd be like it's James
hilly Bob like I didn't know but it was
I don't know it was I was oddly dialed
in on and stuff so I I kind of like it
but Marc at one point came out and
[ __ ] joined us and Marc my big
question is did you did you cut my line
like that was so beautiful
well like I hear no you're right cuz I
don't even know you had a lot I don't
have a lot we got scared for a second I
was like did he say some [ __ ] that I
should have kept in yeah I cut your line
before you get on [ __ ] stage yeah
mark is uh mark is there and he plays
the he's kind of the Dormouse in the
scene cuz I can't well he's it's it'll
spoil it but in the context the scene
mark is sleeping most of it and then
wakes up at one point [ __ ] and it
reminds me of the Dormouse and that was
I was playing a German I wasn't really
method yeah what was it like you're
going to sleep what you're going to
sleep as if he's the sleep of death and
then he is going to say nothing and yeah
I'm glad I didn't give you a [ __ ]
line no I was I was I was talking to the
other two guys here in the scene with me
you also flew in for the day and I'm
like I'm gonna get a [ __ ] line I'm
gonna do hopefully gonna build a
character do a thing and then he's gonna
say I'm gonna [ __ ] just say it I'm
gonna come to go because I'm gonna steal
my space and then they go to Mike the
other two guys they don't give me a mic
[ __ ] I spent the last six hours
building his internal story I remember
the moments do with her like we're
miking up Chris and Jessi do we mic up
mark and I was like no he can't talk
he's not an actor
[Applause]
but I mean technically I'm not saying he
can never act but he was not classified
as an actor it wasn't classified as an
extra probably scenery yeah you were
kind of a prop in the scene so yeah he
couldn't [ __ ] talk or else all the
sudden they'd have to pay him like two
grand or some [ __ ] and we didn't have
the money because of your hand yeah very
much [ __ ] right this is where you spend
the time and to be fair I didn't give
myself a line so [ __ ] you yeah man it
was it was a good time like I said like
everybody I loved was there and even
[ __ ] mark was there and stuff so it
was it was pretty sweet and I'll be able
to share more with you as we move on
like what is it right now 420 which
we'll talk about in a second of course
by Comic Con which is only like three
months away yeah
I'm sure I'll be ready to be like here I
want to show you something
Wow and I assure you it will not be my
dick do you collect minifigs is that
what palpable disappointment all right
in any event [ __ ] all that [ __ ] reboot
went well we but I shouldn't you know
what before I go further I should say
you know all throughout the movie I was
instagramming like look who's here look
who's here and [ __ ] I was so very
excited obviously and you know the
producers were like would you stop
[ __ ] giving everyone away and I was
like you know I'm not giving everyone
away and stuff like that but I'm like
I'm on it for years we've been going
like we're gonna make [ __ ] clerks
three and it didn't happen we're gonna
make Mallrats two and it didn't happen
I'm like we're gonna make Jay and Silent
Bob it took two years to get here and
almost died at one [ __ ] point [ __ ] so
I wanted to prove like here's photo
proof it's [ __ ] happening and [ __ ]
proof of life yeah oh my god so I kept
throwing up pictures and [ __ ] one of the
things I was going to keep very quiet
the other cat spoiled man Chris
Hemsworth jumped on to his Instagram
account and put up a picture and he was
like I'm in Jay and Silent Bob reboot
which he is and it was awesome and [ __ ]
but I didn't think we were gonna be able
to talk about it until like the movie
came out and stuff but like god of
thunder wants what he wants just dropped
it out there and I was like my turn and
I got to Instagram it as well but yeah
it was awesome and he was absolutely
[ __ ] awesome he's hysterical in the
movie and stuff but I'm not gonna tell
you about that I'm gonna tell you about
the PS so we shot with them and then
afterwards he go it's like so you know
I'll see you at the premiere and I was
like yeah of course you will and he was
like you're not going I was like no no I
don't have a ticket to that and he goes
oh do you want to go as my guest and I
was like so [ __ ] yeah man I'm gonna hold
his hammer all night I don't think I'm
is I don't think I'm is like I'm she's
got a bride so I'm sure him and his wife
are going together but I'm one of his
guests yes you are worthy of holding the
hammer apparently yeah man oh man how
cool so that is happening on Monday
Monday yeah yeah downtown so I mean
we're only what is it we're one week
less than a week now yeah always the man
game five days and technically I you
know [ __ ] could wait until Friday or
Thursday night but [ __ ] that like I want
to go see it in that [ __ ] room where
with all the people with all the
Avengers in the [ __ ] room and [ __ ]
plus more importantly I want to see it
before it gets spoiled like I've already
almost hit two articles online that like
they didn't bury the [ __ ] lead they
did bury the lead in their in their
headline so that I got like a paragraph
in before all the sudden I was like oh
wow tell me [ __ ] oh my god it's like
walking in and your dad getting dressed
yeah so I just I you know I'm I'm
looking forward to seeing it Monday I
just that means I have to stay [ __ ]
pure for 48 hours and not [ __ ] hear
anything's I would love to go and clean
I've made it this far I mean I know as
much as everybody else based on the
[ __ ] trailers and [ __ ] like that
I think I think I think fans will be
respectful I think the press can be
[ __ ] but anything fans will be
respectful and I know this only because
standing under the [ __ ] Winterfell
tree Game of Thrones fans knew about the
red wedding years before it appeared on
TV and said nothing the fact that every
now and again
fans will lock some [ __ ] up in a vault
and keep it secret keep it safe and
never let it slip probably because they
just want to see the look on your face
when that [ __ ] happens all right I'm
like no no no it's just another episode
here no no they're gonna have dinner
have a dinner right now
[ __ ] don't worry don't go to the
bathroom set you're gonna be here for
them so gonna want to be through this so
like every now and again we come sure
the book fans were like there's no way
they're ever gonna [ __ ] do this in a
TV show and even they when they saw the
episode were like oh [ __ ] it's more
horrifying than on the page I'll never
forget what I was doing I was bad I was
falling asleep at my desk watching that
episode and I was like you know what I
just put it pause it and I'm gonna go
and wake up in the morning and watch the
rest and then it just you know the
[ __ ] rains of castamere began and I
was like oh so I must be at the end of
the episode they're playing music and
spoilers [ __ ] got stabby real quick and
I went from [ __ ] leg ready didn't
have to like what the no not her back
like oh it's horrifying and [ __ ] and I
stayed up for three more hours watching
more episodes going who else are they
gonna kill I think that there's I'm
hoping that this is a world in which if
you see it on Monday BC you know Tuesday
I think press screening star on Tuesday
if you go [ __ ] Thursday night where
I'm gonna be there we will keep it
somewhat contained until like Monday
because if you haven't seen it by Monday
you just don't care enough like and I
know some people like I've got
responsibilities I've got children man
it's like wow
prioritize movie over children [ __ ]
bring the children you get shows kids
364 days of the [ __ ] year one day
give to the Avengers that's it that's
all know people find their way at time
to seeing it but it will be tough not to
speak about when is the next show that
we do the Monday Tuesday after all right
so I just have to wait till then and at
that point [ __ ] everybody yeah that's a
good four or five days watching this
podcast then you will have seen an
opening that's true it's true and then
you know unless you're the hospital I
get it and then I'm sorry like be
friends with an Avenger who'll bring you
the [ __ ] movie they do stop by
hospitals quite apparently that would
have been a way to see the movie early
thankfully I got invited so I'm gonna do
that it's gonna be a good time today is
4/20 it is indeed
national holiday for those of us who are
travelers of the [ __ ] green tourist
holiday for people who are like oh my
god I want to get high today I was
driving up here and there was a line
outside of a dispensary yes
yeah it's try anything today it's I
don't know it's a look I'm not one of
those people that's like hey man I liked
weed when it was cool like [ __ ] more
the merrier I love when everybody's in
on it [ __ ] but it's tough to like you
know when I pulled up marks like happy
weed Christmas and I was like I don't
know it's just a day of the week for me
I really couldn't figure out like how do
I celebrate this any [ __ ] differently
than I was like oh I had a fatter joint
than normal that was it
so but it's a wonderful it's weird and
wonderful that it's caught on and [ __ ]
like that
I left somebody who I was I was editing
all morning I got up cuz I had the
little screening last night so when I
woke up this one I was gonna dive back
into it so I was editing right up until
I want to take a shower to come here
so that's when I finally saw Jen so Jen
woke up hours before and stuff but I
didn't really see her till this point so
I headed into the room and she's sitting
there she's like hey and I say hey man I
said I'm gonna shower and go to the
cantina do Fatman beyond you want to go
she was like and she's sitting out - she
goes she's really thinking about going
with you earlier and then I was reading
about 420 on Twitter and I started
getting FOMO so I smoked one of those
little joints and she's like now I just
want to lay down to Wednesday which
little joint did she smoke and she
smokes [ __ ] that was like [ __ ] ground
out of moon rocks is just like for those
who don't [ __ ] [ __ ] with that kind of
[ __ ] it's like you know it for her to
smoke a normal Joyce she's not really a
STONER at all she never smokes would
have been [ __ ] you know intense
enough she just she took on the crack
cocaine a [ __ ] of weed man and so she
was just like oh my god I feel so
[ __ ] high she's like my face is all
scrunched I was like oh if it's any
consolation I did not know that you were
high at all she's like yeah yeah my
passing and I was like well not now No
so she's like I was gonna go to the club
but I just can't do it I think I'd be a
[ __ ] mess right now how do you do
this all the time and I'm like I don't
know it's fun for me and so she got him
to lay down I was like copy back in a
couple hours and [ __ ] so she's laying
down and I honestly what she smoked I
don't think will pass by the time I get
home I think I'm gonna get home and
she's gonna be a cat white state of
readiness
this is it 421 yet you you you haven't
been training to direct and star in a
movie you've been training for 420 yeah
and so like your body is ready for that
[ __ ] no no this is that this is the
serious chronic and like but you're just
like you lost all the way you look great
but you were in training for movie mode
yeah training for 420 all my whole life
I've been training for 420 and stuff it
is it's I don't know it's it's a it's
you were saying that you passed a line
on the way here I passed the dispensary
as well I couldn't be the same one where
was yours uh Cahuenga
just north of Sunset that's a different
[ __ ] dispensary than the one that I
passed and the one I passed had a
[ __ ] line what do they know that we
don't I don't know anything as a
midnight we're getting rid of all the
way you know I guess it's just a bunch a
people like hey man it's the [ __ ]
holiday do you have a tree
do I have a tree yeah it's weak
Christmas like do you put up a tree and
I got wreaths I smoke my trees no I
don't put object I don't put up
decorations for the real Christmas am I
gonna do it for [ __ ] weed Christmas
you just do still do decorations yeah do
you really yeah I do I don't want to but
I have children that's right yeah but we
had a kid and we never really I mean the
tree and [ __ ] of course but like on the
outside of the house no you don't do
that I don't do that because I'm a bad
father yeah me too my kids like you know
it'd be cool like outside decorations
I'm like you know it wouldn't be cool
but it's not gonna happen you look
across the street they got it you can
enjoy there it's as much as you could
have enjoyed ours it's like living in
New Jersey you get to see New York look
at all that culture alright [ __ ] it yes
funny so happy 4/20
all right it's been a long [ __ ] time
yes we should dive in and talk about you
I feel so weird as I look in front of me
there's lots of stuff as always to sign
on the bar but this [ __ ] happened as
well Detective Comics 1000 came out and
I had a story in it which in any other
[ __ ] year like that would have been
my whole years leading up to this
[ __ ] [ __ ] but I was in the middle of
Megan reboot when this happened so it
was just something that I'm like oh yeah
by the way this happened and then right
back into the [ __ ] movie but this was
a [ __ ] for a guy who you know has
co-hosted fat man on Batman and fat man
Beyond now for years to be involved in
Detective Comics 1000 like that's that
they can't take that away from you no
story drawn by Jim [ __ ] Lee I buried
the lead
Jim Lee do the [ __ ] story yeah when
they asked me they didn't even tell me
about Jim Lee at first they were just
like hey Dee he wanted your story for a
detective 1000 I was like oh my god yeah
that'd be fun they're like Jim Lee's
gonna draw it I'm like you you [ __ ]
think to add that later like was this
some kind of [ __ ] test but I it was
eating a wonderful [ __ ] job and stuff
it wasn't beautiful to be a part of it
and I'm just so delighted to talk about
because generally like when I do [ __ ]
people like you [ __ ] suck but this
story I didn't get that people were just
like you know what good job
yeah even the hostile people were just
like I'm the worst I got was somebody
was like it's a little trick Lee and I'm
like well [ __ ] yeah it's Detective
Comics 1000 it's a story that's kind of
close to his heart literally and
figuratively and stuff so uh but I was
delighted that people kind of went for
it and [ __ ] and they were like it should
have been longer gives only a pages but
I think if it went longer they wouldn't
have liked it as much I would have
[ __ ] it up on like here's a walrus and
now Batman pees himself like with it
with eight pages I couldn't [ __ ] myself
man so that's what I should do in the
future keep everything short keep it
tight I like this story quite a bit and
while that was going on hip girl has
been happening I got to write Hit Girl
for Mark Millar and it's I'm now at
issue three I think issue 4 comes out in
in like two weeks or something like
you've been making [ __ ] I have and that
book was received well I kept expecting
like people to [ __ ] on that book as well
and people like nah man it's [ __ ] fun
and she had and I was smart cuz I
brought her Neil on to that book who
we've had here on the show and people
like her her art look quite a bit
they're like oh my god it's juxtaposed
against the violence it's really fun and
[ __ ]
so two comic book projects man for you
know we talk about other people's comic
book [ __ ] I got to do to mount and so
far both have worked out there's one
where she to go hit girl so maybe at the
end of it people like [ __ ] you you
ruined it but like right now people seem
to dig a [ __ ] girl and so forth
oh my god that is that's the review I'm
waiting I don't really read my mind
but yeah so is weird seeing him here I'm
gonna to tag him of course but a huge
honor like look all the [ __ ] we talk
about here generally we wind up talking
about the the sexy the movies the TV
shows and stuff like that
but it all begins right here with the
printed page and in my fascination for
and love of this [ __ ] began with the
printed page man like I didn't [ __ ]
stumble into a Batman movie I stumbled
into an issue of Batman when I was a kid
so like to be involved in in the the
world of you know what some people call
pamphlets but the paper world of
storytelling you know where all these
amazing multi-billion dollar franchises
have their humble origins and to throw
one more spoke on the wheel really cool
[ __ ] thing I just want to shout also
I'm plugging him go by those in any
event what's news saith thou mark
barnard lazy gem is it was a news man
once upon a time once upon a time he was
a guy that [ __ ] saw all the news that
was fit to print and major publications
and now he's a [ __ ] writer but on the
weekends
he'll gather some news just for us here
at the cantina man marks got fat man
Beyond news give it up for Marquis read
the news news and copy pasted [ __ ] from
the internet were you working on that
song while I was away I really was man
how'd it come out it was pretty good
should I cut a demo workshop at a little
more well somebody have a sharpie
what is this giant thing before we dive
into the news what is this who brought
this
it's a board game are you [ __ ] me
all right we'll talk about this later on
holy [ __ ] man Wow
are there two separate ones for me and
him one for me and one for the audience
just [ __ ] mark yeah no worries we'll
talk about it later that looks [ __ ]
amazing all right man so news a couple
of quick pops yeah I saw some [ __ ] in
theaters what televisions I saw shoes am
that's the general consensus I have not
gone yet my kid went absolutely loved it
I spoke to Ralph Garman on Hollywood
babble-on he loved it how do you feel I
really liked it super fun I didn't love
it but it is doing the thing that I
didn't love it cuz it had magic and
Wonder it so [ __ ] that noise oh my god
man it's like after kicking these fools
in the nuts for years over their [ __ ]
treatment of Batman and the Justice
League they finally give you something
light and you're like yeah it's alright
but it is super fun I really liked it
it's it is exactly what DC should be
doing which is we don't need to actually
have a connected universe we're just
gonna make some good fun movies that
slice where you need them to slice now
does this take place in the DC movie
universe it does but in in in as much as
there's a shot of a Batarang and
somebody who is not Henry Cavill
in a super suit that uranium is his head
beyond that it is it the super suit from
a steel so it's meant to be with yeah oh
that's cool but beyond that like it
doesn't really touch that much into it
right but it's super fun zack levy is
having a blast you know it's it's a
battery door he's a sweet guy it's about
family that in a really nice way and the
whole idea that that soup that the
family that you make is as important if
not more so than the family are born
into right like as we go forth into the
world you will leave the family unit the
family home the nuclear
whatever and go off into the world and
you will begin to glom and and draw
people into your own orbit and the
people you get to choose and the people
you get to invite in are as important if
not a little bit more so and so tiling
an adoption storytelling a foster
storytelling those sort of things and
then the family that you build as the
most of the family you inherit it's
really kind of cool
my one tiny problem is that like I hate
children I hate children but my problem
is that I love big oh of course you
don't love big everybody looks big and
part of what makes big work so well is
that the when you meet Josh as a 12 year
old kid and then you see Tom Hanks they
are fundamentally the same character and
you can tell because Tom Hanks is acting
like he's a kid he's acting and and you
could actually buy that that person is
that person just in a bigger body okay I
never bought that the kid who's playing
Billy Batson acted character wise
performance wise is the same person that
exactly why is playing and that it was
it was I'm kind of like from the back
like the wizard Shazam yes my name the
young Billy Batson is like kind of
withdrawn in an inward and a little kind
of closer than and he's all up in his
own head and when he gets powers he
turns into like a weird frat bro guy
who's like super excited about beer and
let's go to strip clubs and like I would
get that if that was also what young
Billy Batson was like right like those
the thread between those two feels a
little weird and and in the comics how
close is Billy Batson to Captain Marvel
tubes I'm sorry Shazam yeah I mean its
trademark Marvel there was a transition
between the two no I mean it's
especially in the beginning especially
when you first meet like no I'm just
asking in general have you ever read
much Shazam I've read a handful of it
you know and most of the ones that I've
read haven't been like origin stories so
the Billy Batson of like later it has
been exam for a minute yeah he rides
that particular I didn't know if they
were meant to be two distinct purse
analogies like is billy batson isn't
Shazam where is he that what in the in
the world of Shazam is is that is Zach
Levi what Billy Batson will look like
when he grows up yes so it's not just
this other individual like miracle man
Alan Moore wrote miracle man they were
completely different [ __ ] beings who
just used like a human housing system
it's right no this is supposed to be
like oh no we made you this is who
you're going to be this is the best
version of you and so you are the same
person fundamentally you're still 1/12
they can't even get away with that they
can't even quite get away with that oh I
tried Suzanne you did your best and so
by the time you get to the end of the
movie it is very very like punchy punchy
smashy-smashy like kind of traditional
superhero movie and I wanted it to be
about how a child would solve this
problem you know and it isn't it's how I
would punch a guy in the face a lot and
like there's there's some old story that
lands like a childish way to solve a
problem kind of but it's not like it
doesn't have a shift in perspective
right like I've grown up in the third
act where there's a story about like
there's there's it was in Manhattan
somewhere and there's a truck that got
stuck in a tunnel that was too high like
it didn't clear the clearance it was
wedged in and everybody's [ __ ] around
it with like cranes and forklifts and
and the cops in the firemen and
everybody's there trying to figure out
how to get this [ __ ] truck out and
like a kid in a car who's waiting to go
through the tunnel was like just let the
air out of the tires and like nobody
else there would have thought of that
because everybody there was like well
you have these [ __ ] machines we're
[ __ ] groves we know what to do and
they kid solving a problem in a way that
an adult wouldn't have it's kind of what
I wanted that movie to be I'm sorry what
I just caught on was that was not a
scene from Shazam you just described
that it's just a an an ague thing are
you [ __ ] me they got all the money
in the world no like will in this action
sequence they let some air out of the
tires I'm like [ __ ] I could have
directed that you're saying you would
like to seen some that kind of kid
ingenuity right like that let that be
the thing that makes him special god
damn it stop [ __ ] making better
movies in your head than everybody else
that is a good idea that would make a
lot of sense it's instead of just punchi
punchi
what was the punchi punchi better hold
on it is now 4:20 that's the show
everybody good night somewhere Snoop
Dogg just got his wings you know huh all
right so what's barring that barring
that it's a lot of fun barring that it's
it's it is a successful outing it's made
almost a billion dollars worldwide I
think what yeah it's doing really well
Shazam
no chasm Captain Marvel just hit a
billion rows it almost somebody pull up
some [ __ ] figures it came out to
inform you know it would have much faith
you've lost in me somebody consult the
Internet yeah I don't trust that a
stranger it would have to be [ __ ]
Nolan's Dark Knight to be almost a
billion at this point yeah you did make
that up I did make that out I see some
diligence he going on over there
somebody's gonna scream it out yeah
they're gonna get me like the 675 or
whatever it really I don't even think
they're at 500 yeah and I'm not I'm not
saying like they suck I'm just like
that's a huge [ __ ] figure man like
again Captain Marvel just hit a billion
a couple weeks ago where we at what do
we got
how much 390 you're right it is a
billion dollars mark it's a billion more
than I have but still that's [ __ ]
huge especially for can you imagine we
have a Shazam movie we do like that that
hadn't happened before these be a
Captain Marvel TV show when I was kid
we're in which he said the word Shazam
but now we got a full full-blown she's a
movie that is making so much money
they're making another one and I
understand they probably have to make
another one as quickly as possible
because isn't Billy Batson gonna grow up
in real life and not look like Zack Levi
probably so they better make another one
be quick right speaking of movies that
that we have seen before I saw Hellboy
oh [ __ ] the that came out when did that
come out came out like two weeks ago
and will be gone very shortly
it didn't work out for our boy it did
not work out so well for our boy
what who directed anybody no Neil
Marshall who's that he did the descent
he did that's good movie he did like
three or four episodes of Game of
Thrones including I think the Battle of
Blackwater Bay
are you [ __ ] serious yeah yes yeah no
he's I don't they give him all the
movies I don't know but I will say that
I I have a weird love for the Guillermo
del Toro Hellboy movies yeah
the first one is okay and I love the
second one the second one is the Golden
Army the Golden Army but that movie has
such a love and a pathos for Hellboy as
a character like it it cares enough to
make him a monster because what Gama
loves more than anything is monsters
monsters and to sympathize with monsters
are identified with monsters and to let
you ride with what makes that guy
special this movie traded that love for
brutality and so like it's just gory
it's just like like apparently we needed
F words in a ho boy movie because that
will make it better I guess were there
none in the previous no the other ones
are like pg-13 ooh
because games like this should be a
fable that you could take a kid to these
you absolutely cannot take a kid to
because they're like ripping faces off
ghetto kids are cool with that in which
case go for it it's a very gory version
it's a very gory version this Mike
Mineola was involved right he was my ta
âlâ was involved I think he's an
executive producer II consult on the
script but it for me it was just a case
of we didn't really need another Hellboy
movie and if we were gonna get one we
don't need another boy although Hellboy
Beyond Thunderdome people sitting on
he's gonna have this [ __ ] movie
happen I'm like wow there's these guys
were stoned on 4/20 Oh the and also it's
speaking of which like it didn't he just
Mineola just wrapped up that beep BPRD
book which has been going on with a
storyline has been going on for I guess
the better part of 20 [ __ ] years
yeah it's a huge accomplishment anything
away from no [ __ ] he's a amazing
artist and that characters fantastic and
stuff but it sounds like the movie
didn't pan and one of the few characters
from comic books not created by Marvel
or DC to not get one not get two but to
get three [ __ ] movies like that is
it's amazing that it even exists and
let's be honest it's gonna probably get
in our lifetime you'll probably see two
more incarnations of Hellboy I know
gotta be right because it captures like
visually graphic it captures people's
imaginations it may not happen for like
ten years or more but it's it's too good
a property to cinematically to not touch
again it'll come around especially when
like by the time they touch it again you
won't even have to put on the makeup
yeah he'll just be CG Hellboy the whole
thing I saw a trailer for a Star Wars
movie how was David Harbor in it uh he's
good he's good like he's goofy he's a
bit of a goober and that's exactly kind
of what you want right did you see a
trailer first Star Wars movie I did did
you do 20 minutes on that I saw I saw
the trailer as well for the rise of
Skywalker
yeah what do you think I've already
[ __ ] blown it online so I could still
taste it in my mouth
that was from days ago I just won't wash
it off oh my god I love it so much I
love bantha hair yes what was that was
that too much it's a bridge too far
what uh what were your feelings on it I
I loved it to death and I love it in the
same way that I love all things Star
Wars in that it I could watch that I
could listen to that trailer and be
happy because so much of it at this
point it's just like this weird dopamine
rush of nostalgia and and sensation and
like when that music [ __ ] kicks in
and it's just it's everything you want
to Star Wars thing to be I tend to feel
that way about everything Star Wars that
I get because it tickles those parts of
my brain that make me feel seven again
yes and every time I hear a [ __ ]
lightsaber click on like its oh [ __ ]
Star Wars yeah I'll take
all of this however much you have I want
and that's how I felt about the trailer
and I love the trailer even more when
you pit when you put what's up danger on
top of the trailer if you haven't heard
that mashup it's phenomenal you put it
on top of that trail yeah someone she
jumps on the [ __ ] typewriter ha ha
what's up danger and she's just
upside-down and then it kicks in and
it's perfect I'm gonna look for it
online [ __ ] perfect all the time it
is it's a fantastic trailer we got into
a discussion on Hollywood babble-on
about fanservice you know because it is
it's fanservice to the highest degree
when you watch that trailer fanservice
by like putting the name Scott Walker in
the trailer fanservice but here's a shot
of Lando fanservice by like here's a
piece of the Death Star fanservice but I
like a [ __ ] c-3po still in this [ __ ]
[Music]
fanservice like left and right the you
know the Emperor's laughs it's all
[ __ ] fanservice and I know some
people get irritated by that but I don't
understand why it's like why would you
like that's what a sequel is a sequel is
fanservice it's not continuation of a
story it's not another artistic
statement if there was no call for it if
there was no interest in it if there was
no money to be made from it they
wouldn't [ __ ] go forward with the
story story be over with the first movie
Star Wars would have been hittin [ __ ] so
the moment they were like holy [ __ ]
people like this stupid [ __ ] then it
becomes fanservice now nothing wrong
with that man and if you could do it
artfully and if you pour your all into
it if you satisfy the [ __ ] fans
that's the name of the game I don't
understand people that are like there's
too much [ __ ] fanservice on my Jesus
Christ the last time somebody made some
Star Wars movies guy was like I'm not
doing fanservice guess what you know how
you become a Jedi blood disease [ __ ]
like that's how
[ __ ] your fan service like and everyone
got so mad they were like he's not
listening to us well I won't he lives
with the [ __ ] pants and now all they
do is go like one of the fans that want
here this is what the vent and instantly
people like too [ __ ] much man too
much fanservice like take my dick out of
your mouth you know like I'm all for it
man you show me that kind of fanservice
like that's what I'm paying for I'm not
pay honestly like with all due respect
to whatever they do after this [ __ ]
saga is finished and [ __ ] I'm I'm not
paying to go on new adventures I want to
see old [ __ ] friends that's why
they're gonna get my [ __ ] money cuz
I'm like show me my friends that's it
you have my friends held hostage I will
give you money if you show me my friends
I want to know they're alive I want to
know that they're still friends and [ __ ]
then I want to go home and I'll go on
with my [ __ ] life so I honestly feel
like I saw that trailer is fanservice to
the highest degree artful fanservice Jay
Jay is a fantastic filmmaker so it all
looks like oh my god he just knows how
to [ __ ] do it he's the John Williams
of directors man it's just like he just
composes and sanely [ __ ] well so you
know in some people i somebody [ __ ]
hit me on twitter yesterday they were
like man you [ __ ] blow disney all the
time and focus Star Wars and Marvel and
[ __ ] and I was like bro I [ __ ] I've
been blowing Star Wars since 1994 in
clerks I've been blowing Marvel since 95
and mar'ied you just noticed now like
I'm a [ __ ] fan of this [ __ ] I started
as a fan of this [ __ ] long before I was
a filmmaker and [ __ ] I know some people
are like he's a [ __ ] filmmaker and he
should be more discerning some of these
Marvel movies okay but he [ __ ] loves
them all yes I do I don't sit there and
go like well that could have been better
give a [ __ ] [ __ ] because I sit there
and go could never [ __ ] yeah that's what
he's here for my job that's what he does
I sit there and go like I can't do that
I could never do that I didn't I would
never even think to do that [ __ ] you
know and even sometimes when you're
watching the movie you know like oh I
bet you I think I know what's gonna
happen
that's predicated on some [ __ ] that they
did before that I wouldn't have [ __ ]
thought of myself so I love this [ __ ]
because it reduces me to fandom again
that's how I started and that's how
eventually I'll finish I was a fan I got
lucky enough to make some [ __ ] and
whatnot but one day I'm gonna start one
day they're gonna be
enough you suck at this and I have to go
back to being a fan and and like I'm I
that when I see that trailer when I see
an end game trailer or any one of the
[ __ ] like 10-second spots that them
dropping online for I collect the last
week and shed it is just like you said
before it makes me feel like I'm [ __ ]
seven and it it it's the cheapest
[ __ ] time machine there is cheapest
[ __ ] feel-good drug there is man and
it's like you know non-invasive
addictive it won't destroy your life if
you're like I want to watch all these
Marvel movies it'll destroy your [ __ ]
weekend but like it won't [ __ ]
destroy your [ __ ] life your marriage
yeah what find somebody that's like I
want to watch them all - and there's
your [ __ ] mate for life and [ __ ] like
that
so III don't know when I saw that
trailer I was like this is absolute
[ __ ] perfection like this is this is
no perfect for what it needs to be I
think it reached out to anybody who felt
you know left behind by [ __ ] the last
two Star Wars movies or whatever - [ __ ]
or like hey man they say my stores
anymore you can't watch that trailer and
be like that ain't my [ __ ] Star Wars
it's like oh my god it looks like your
childhood [ __ ] look at Lando laughing
in the cockpit man like he's like I got
it back after all [ __ ] on oh my god I'm
gonna pay to see that alone the
satisfied smirk of like ahaha last one
standing will get your girl - oh wait
yeah what the [ __ ] you lost them all
right what else we got one one last
thing that I saw that I want to give
some love to is a movie called fast
colour which was directed and written by
Julia Hart
starring Gugu mbatha-raw as a woman
named Ruth who has a power that she
can't control and understand oh right I
think I read about this movie yeah it's
a low-budget super power mode it is like
the Terminator if it was an x-men movie
in that the first Terminator cost like
six million dollars yeah and all of the
ingenuity that movies in the script it's
all on the page it's all super smart the
weight
information and complicates this woman's
life and like there are some puppets
that's kind of all that you get out of
terminator but it's it's think of a bug
in the entry for Earth in the
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy mostly
harmless you know like and there's some
puppies but it is this story about like
these three generations of women each of
which has some kind of ability that
they're learning how to control who've
been hiding for generations in the
middle of nowhere Midwest in a world
where it has stopped raining and hasn't
rained in like eight years and so water
scarcity is for real
and just the way it builds this world in
the web builders characters and how they
want what they want to need what they
need and how their powers complicate
those needs the performances are great
and the the kick in from the middle of
the movie to the end of the movie hit me
like a [ __ ] hammer like I sat there
in a theater by myself
Friday morning crying because this movie
just you just sold the ticket man to you
[ __ ] yeah oh I [ __ ] I'll get so baked
and cry my eyeballs out Man Alive I
don't care if anybody's there by myself
that's that's that's how you get me in a
movie theater now like you're gonna feel
something you're gonna feel something if
some of it is also like it's it's
emotional and it's revelatory but it's I
can't believe they stuck the landing as
well as they did in this movie really
yeah like everything that they set up
and all of the emotional trajectories
are all over them what kind of budget
you think four million five million
maybe compared to was it like remember
that movie in terms of scope and size
remember that movie it's got [ __ ]
General Zod in it what's a Terence Stamp
no the other generals Michael Shannon
yeah and like the kid has yes yeah it's
it's a little smaller than that okay but
if really because that little bit is
constant if I to describe you the tone
it's it's looper meets Logan
ooh yeah and they'd be next to each
other in the video store just for you
looper Logan I'm gonna take these both
home but it actually Logan looper
alphabetically but at its core it's an
x-men movie at its core it's about like
here's this woman who has powers and
can't control them and needs to learn
how in order to move on with her life
and it's about kids and it's about a
Dust Bowl and it's about genre at a very
elevated way I love it to death it's in
like 25 theaters this weekend it'll
disappear next weekend because Avengers
will eat every screen in the world yeah
because three hours and two minutes
requires I'm having every [ __ ] screen
in the world to make their money back
but it'll if you can't make it it's only
in like the [ __ ] Sherman Oaks
Arclight and somewhere in Baldwin Hills
the center mark 12 in Baldwin Hills
it'll be streaming shortly thereafter I
have to hope but watch it it's glorious
so far the best movie I saw all year
fucking-a yeah that's huge view who's
the director Julia Hart anything else um
she made a couple of other small movies
that I don't know she co-wrote and
co-produced with her husband I'm Jordan
Horowitz who produced lala land right
you know and was like the dude who kind
of classically gave the Oscar to be dude
who was on stage like we didn't win that
we didn't win it like moonlight guys
know for real come on up he's the
co-writer this movie yeah co-writer and
producer so like you know it's it was it
small one more time
fast color fast color and it'll make
sense once you see it reign play a
factor lack of rain yes cuz you really
included that in the setup yeah no but
it's also because it highlights how much
we take water for granted and if you
don't have it how much it makes life
harder
if you then have to pay like I can get a
motel room for 32 bucks a night you want
water that's another $40 for like a half
a gallon of water because that's what it
costs when you don't have any more right
and so just the building of that world
and the making that feel like a texture
and a reality and the deprivation of
that and the hopelessness of a world
without that and how these main
characters play into that you know it's
great fuckin'-a we show the ticket man
fast color fast color go see all right
so that's all the [ __ ] that you saw I
haven't seen any oh I've seen Jay and
Silent Bob
a number of times boy it's enjoyable but
I haven't really seen other than Game of
Thrones I haven't seen anything new
I did see no have I are we talk I talked
about Captain Marvel I think at one
point did I did I ever tell you I did I
loved it obviously but I mean yeah I
loved it not that all right yeah that
seemed and we're a little late on that
all right that's not news it's right as
we're supposed to get in the news yes
you know they were making a why the last
man show
I remember hearing that did we talk
about it here or who have read it I
think I think Wayne was a president the
IRA Keegan is playing Yorick boys making
it Michael Greene who did American Gods
and oscar-nominated he had that [ __ ]
year he had the year of all years he did
it was it was it was Logan American and
gods Murder on the Orient Express and
alien covenant I think don't it make you
feel like would you do that here like I
jerked off a lot i pod casted like once
every couple that we hear I watch all
the Marvel Netflix shows which was a
wise investment of time because then
they cancelled every one of them do you
see the [ __ ] it was probably happened
while we were away but Punisher got
canceled and [ __ ] Eminem tweeted at
Netflix he was like canceling Punisher
Burger Punisher bad idea so I've just
delighted me know and I'm like stars
they are just like us well even [ __ ]
Eminem was pissed off about that idea or
Marshall Mathers is gonna come for you
seeing our song is kind of nice to know
that he stands for [ __ ] The Punisher
my Heat apparently he really does
alright so yeah Michael Green was having
a [ __ ] he was having a [ __ ] year
so he was sure winning this with eater
crow who was on the cage and they were
[ __ ] off to the races and then they
put out a tweet saying we were saddened
to be able to have to tell you that this
version of Y the last man will no longer
go forward
FX did not see the show that we saw we
have nothing but love for the cast and
we really hope that you get to see the
show that you deserve
but we're walking away whoa yeah and so
for like half an hour it was did FX just
cancel why the last man how do you catch
some weather let's man they shot a pilot
they're in production they got scripts
but it's just that they walked away from
the show over what I have to assume are
pretty intense creative differences
because it takes a lot to get a
showrunner or a creator to walk away
from their own show but it just must be
that they fundamentally saw a different
show than FX did and I think FX was like
what if Y the last man was a woman what
if he wasn't the last man I like that
let's keep that going what if there were
other men what if it was like our world
what if it was like Sex in the City
can you do that can you do that and also
with the money you can keep the monkey
we're fine we can keeping the monkey
just like there's like 50% dudes here
they didn't have monkey in Sex in the
City you're right kill the monkey so yes
they are walking away from the show and
so just that's it nothing more than
creative differences nothing more than
creative differences which saddens me
because I love Michael's work and I
think that he has a pretty unique
Sensibility and absolutely understood
what that world was and kind of needed
to be and so for them to have a lack of
faith in what that world was for and for
the network to not to I'm sure having
had a thousand meetings about what it
was and to get this far into it to get
to a point where where there's no
compromise and nobody wants to walk away
from a TV show not the least of which
you make a [ __ ] mint to do that and
so to walk away from a tons of [ __ ]
money but be a show that you loved is
it's a pretty serious thing it's a shame
he doesn't have like 19 other things to
do that's totally true like a work like
death on the Nile the the sequel to
murder they were in express which he's
writing yeah that's right they're doing
another one they do another one with
Letitia right just signed on to do that
Sheree is now going to kill the
[ __ ] on the Nile
Wow yeah right that's cool where'd you
read that you know the Internet
what is that all right well that's
[ __ ] weird news so wait why is
happening just now why is happening the
schedule is gonna change I think the
pilot that they shot is gonna still air
but they're they're looking for new show
runners at the moment hmm do we the
phone ring yep
yes hello yeah I can be your last man
it's truly late cheerleader why not me
oh that's why of course yeah I get it I
mean well but now it's like there's
nobody doing it so I know I could just
show up just I said show me on the job
and everyone just like - is he is either
guy see the guy do I get to all call me
anything just okay I guess you're the
guy yeah just you know see it and be it
what do you want for lunch food I think
he's the guy he's really upset the
lunches in here totally television
writer speaking of shows that are sadly
not going to exist in the way we thought
that they were Swamp Thing I saw a
trailer for Swamp Thing is or teaser
yeah now they're teasing it they're
still launching it on May 31st like they
always planned to but it is going to be
three episodes shy of the 13 episodes
that they ordered and it is not going to
get a second season so it's a series
miniseries a miniseries at this point
and they told the writers as they were
in production on like Episode eight
that by the way episode 10 is the end
you had planned for 13 and you would
plan to end the season at 13 you now
kind of have to end the show at 10 so
wrap it up what's the rationale anybody
know the rationale is that there is AT&T
which just bought Warner Brothers yes
wants to launch their own massive
[ __ ] streaming service as doesn't
everybody else the next story will tell
us everywhere in the [ __ ] mother
wants a streaming service what does that
mean for DC universe' precisely they are
now reconsidering the wisdom of having a
DC Universe app at all whether or not it
exists
it's own weather it gets absorbed into
the main AT&T giant Warner verse app
whether the programming that was going
to be there just become something else
whether it's a segment whatever they
don't know yet what I think this is a
casualty of that indecision or at least
the weird and flexion point of we might
not want this but we are committed to
some of this so huh
I mean it's those the DC Universe shows
have been I don't think co-financed by
Netflix or something like Doom Patrol is
I mean yeah yeah like here in the states
and maybe in Canada like Doom Patrol is
on the DC Universe but everywhere else I
think if I'm correct me to correct me if
I'm wrong but I've read online like
people watch it on Netflix so I think
that's what because I remember going
like man this budgets are [ __ ] huge
like there was a Doom Patrol which is an
amazing looking show looks more
expensive than like The CW shows the
flash or Supergirl and somebody who
worked on was like they are and I was
like how how do you get more money than
[ __ ] CW they say the DC Universe has
all that money and [ __ ] I'm gonna call
up Jim Lee Milliken I have a [ __ ]
show
give me one oh my god but they said nah
man they're co-financed like the Netflix
yeah has it overseas so they pay for
like the majority of it here so maybe
Netflix didn't have a piece of Swamp
Thing or something I mean or maybe they
did but even still that's all gonna be
reconsidered because if they're gonna
launch their own giant [ __ ] streaming
app they're not gonna what Netflix to
have a piece of it cuz Netflix is no
competitor that's a shame because that
DC Universe app is pretty awesome it's
pretty good I think they're one of the
problems was they didn't have enough
clearance right like you couldn't down
you couldn't watch anything on a
Playstation or up until last week on an
Xbox you had to be like either on Apple
TV or like a Roku or whatever but the
the access to it was not as robust as it
needed to be and so consequently I don't
think they were having enough eyeballs
on the shows that we're super [ __ ]
expensive and so now Warner's or AT&T
will just do like a [ __ ] Warner verse
app like an 18 T Plus at some point and
and the same way that Disney canceled
though the Netflix shows because they
want to own everything that they do
right that's that might end up happening
with some of the DC Universe shows at
least the ones that they're sharing with
anybody else you and I since we were
born in the 70s and we're children of
the 80s we survived the cola wars will
we survive the streaming wars you think
like everybody's gearing up to [ __ ]
fight each other I mean we'll survive
but there will its Highlander it's there
can be only one
and it's gonna be [ __ ] Disney because
yeah Disney just [ __ ] like unzip the
fly and show the world what they're
gonna do yeah
and it's oh do you like anything we have
it yeah do you want to watch it yeah you
got to come to us yeah like do you want
to remember a fond memory from your
childhood we own it yeah we will give
you access to everything that made you
happy as a child if you give us money
yeah yeah like every [ __ ] happiness
you've ever experienced do it's not even
just like [ __ ] look we got everything
you ever loved we got frozen
[ __ ] which like for people with
little kids that's everything
can you imagine if you got like one of
those little kids is like let it go no
God want to let it go [ __ ]
you'll be able to sit him right in front
of that [ __ ] app and they'll be able
to watch Moana watch all those [ __ ]
movies over knowing everything but [ __ ]
all that [ __ ] the old content they were
showing a [ __ ] where I'm like oh my god
that [ __ ] looks amazing mandalorian
looks [ __ ] fantastic yes and JC was
at celebration so he saw some [ __ ]
yeah and he confirms it looks fantastic
yeah he was like it's Sergio Leone in
the Star Wars universe yeah it's it's
post galactic collapse who profits when
there's no longer a a supreme power and
he said that look we all knew this but
like he confirmed it like it's in the
right hands of Favreau the man I love
Iron Man honestly I feel like Iron Man
is one of the greatest films ever made
like almost a perfect if perfect movie
like there's really no fat on it nothing
wrong with it imaginative his pockets
Star Wars good you know it's just like
wow it's no wonder it launched ten years
worth of [ __ ] movies everything sits
on the very strong
mine of that first movie of iron men
that's all established by Favreau man so
I think he's like really good with his
[ __ ] and when they were starting to
announce Star Wars movies I was like
they should give him one and [ __ ] and he
didn't wind up getting one of the movies
but it sounds like he got something even
better and is doing like the dream show
that we've always wanted to see this is
the first like other than the cartoons
the animated shows the very first Star
Wars live-action TV show and it sounds
like they're not counting like the Ewok
adventures in the [ __ ] the holiday
special
yeah no Christmas special [ __ ] like that
is the first [ __ ] series man and it
looks like they're gonna come out strong
so look they were always gonna get my
money but [ __ ] like when I saw that I
was like oh and when I saw their
easy-to-use layout I'll be honest with
you man they did a show like [ __ ]
Apple does well look how easy it is to
use I was like that is so not complex
and have my money and the thing that's
gonna kill everybody is not just the
amount of content they have is how much
money they are not going to ask you to
give them for it what do you mean look
at that it is $6.99 a month you're
kidding it is $70 a year oh my god that
flicks is now like what bucks a month
the hustle the Hustle is let me give you
the first taste and then like three
years from now yeah
you can't not have this [ __ ] right yeah
that's true you got hooked on The
Simpsons
you want 30 years of The Simpsons [ __ ]
come on welcome right so that will be on
that at launch all 30 seasons of The
Simpsons for how much a month
$6.99 a month it's it's the like we're
gonna kill everybody with our giant
cheap dick look at it the contours if
the Star Wars Marvel Disney Fox universe
it is that's I mean wow what an
incredible loss leader that must be but
I don't know if they lose anything but
it'll probably make all their loot from
the $6 version I mean they're still
gonna make a lot of money it's the money
that they left on the table like if all
you had was there to use of The Simpsons
that's worth a billion dollars to
Netflix or Hulu or anybody like this
massive [ __ ] asset if friends is
worth that
much to Netflix like is a 300 million
dollar deal they decide to get that
stuff Simpsons forget it
they could have cashed in and not giving
a [ __ ] but they're like nope sorry
Netflix we're gonna hold on to this and
we're gonna give it to people for $6.99
a month god that's that's the long game
a long [ __ ] game in addition to every
animated movie Disney's ever made every
movie Pixar's ever made every movie
Marvel's ever made every movie Marvel
that will ever make every Star Wars
[ __ ] do you want to see a drawing or
a hero we own every [ __ ] one of them
every aliens movie even the shitty ones
right they have that would you like to
watch nine years of the x-files
not counting the shitty ones where I was
in [ __ ] Duchovny we have it all wait
are they taking the ones we don't like
out there like that's how good we are we
don't care about which ones you hate
we're gonna take those the [ __ ] out
we're Disney Wow
man so how long do you think before they
jack it up a year or two years I give
them like three or four years because
they also have like other [ __ ]
revenue streams like theme parks where
people go spend all of their money
that's the thing they don't like we're
Netflix Netflix has like we got this
yeah you know if they're not buying
Netflix we are [ __ ] and Disney's like
if they're not buying Disney Plus
they'll buy something else because we
own everything so yeah they're [ __ ]
safest kids I guess they can [ __ ]
just throw that and think about it most
of their financing the cost we're
building whatever tech it is through
which we're gonna stream [ __ ] they
didn't have to pay for the library to
pay for some obviously it's a brand new
content [ __ ] but that library just
sitting there and whatnot yeah so yeah I
guess you could get away with just like
making it cheap Wow
Wow that's true so you see a lot of
people Netflix must be like oh [ __ ] I
mean between [ __ ] like Black Panther
and Thor Ragnarok
and [ __ ] Captain Marvel the four
billion they spent for Marvel it's
already paid off yeah you know there's
six billion they spent on Pixar or he
paid or would they spend on Star Wars
four four billion on Star Wars already
paid ahead of they paid seventy one
billion dollars for Fox that's a lot of
money ten years paid off you think so
yeah is that I mean it's just are you
saying that the way you were elections
and made a billion dollars
it is 4/20 so and I don't smoke at all
but no I mean ten years it feels I'll be
able to put that kind of loot together I
mean you know [ __ ] somebody told me
what Netflix made per month and it was
just it was obscene it was astronomical
it's crazy where you're like and then
you sit there and you're cuz you're like
how and then somebody goes what do you
pay for Netflix and they're like
everybody pays the same thing yeah and
everybody has it you're like oh my god
you're right it's a nobody cancels it
yeah well they might now though huh
because at the end of the day it's just
like wow how much is netflix cost
fourteen fifteen bucks I think at this
point and they keep hiking at every
couple of years because they spend all
that money on content wow it's gonna be
interesting see what happens I wonder
how much how many people will drop or
walk like I you know I'm in a decent
position in life where I'm like well
another app or I [ __ ] just go ahead
put it in like you know but some people
I can't [ __ ] string together like as
many [ __ ] that like I got the CBS app
I never watch it you know I'm saying
like so I know if some people can't if I
could do that and I wonder if you got to
make a choice which choice you going
with I mean I probably like the Disney
app at this point it's a Disney app and
it's absolutely nobody will be buying
cable anymore you know like I know never
mind the Netflix killer this is the
cable killer yeah like what the [ __ ] do
I need you anymore like sports maybe but
I can get that on network could you
imagine like SPN we were there for the
birth of cable and the birth of cable
was like the way the internet opened up
the universe to everybody and [ __ ]
that's what cable TV did and we thought
I could never get better than that man
like they give you a box that had three
rows of buttons on it
so you can watch I don't know 38 Jen yes
38 different [ __ ] channels you're
like oh my god like the channel 4 number
4 and the channel 4 number 11 and then
you rode that [ __ ] thing it was its
reshow time you can watch free porn dude
like you can made it it got a nipple in
the [ __ ] wavy lines when you just
kind of make it like I think what's the
Playboy channel I totally lost it man
and now I have a cable TV [ __ ] raised
us and made us what we are today and now
cable TV is the [ __ ] bus and almost
famous as we head for the [ __ ] plane
a cable tvs like we what happened we're
not good enough anymore but it's like oh
man cable TV if I pay for 96 apps I can
watch anything I want what do you have
what are you give me that I can't get
everywhere else yeah and with you I got
a [ __ ] beat you know attached to a
cable yeah dude's got to come to my
house and install [ __ ] and he's gonna be
here for like four hours that [ __ ]
everything up we are moments away from
most people like gone like cable guy I
don't get it yeah what's that yeah it's
strange yeah sorry cable guys so wait I
bet you here's another way to like
Disney owns most of Hulu at this point
right yep so cuz Fox from Z they'll be
able to bundle those two like you could
see them doing like hey Disney Plus and
Hulu for 9 bucks or so of your network
[ __ ] all of your everything that you
weren't there
you got that ESPN gives you live sports
so [ __ ] everybody else you don't need
that [ __ ] we'll probably be able to
steal the NFL Network at some point
because who cares so football everything
gets to stream through a Disney Plus app
and then everything else will be on
Apple anyway wow what a wonderful
dystopian future you've painted for us
yeah I mean you know I know some part of
me should be alarmed by all this but I'm
like I still keep to get watch it all
right yes yes I know as a content
creator I should be like a man [ __ ]
like you know the people smart people in
this business greed the tea leaves and
like you don't understand all that means
more jobs going away like there's gonna
be one place to get your [ __ ] done man
and if we always go to sell yeah less
places to sell but you know I don't
really sell [ __ ] so I'm like I'm just a
consumer real
when it comes to that stuff if I try to
sell [ __ ] over there like get the [ __ ]
out of here
so I'm more of a consumer and as a
consumer these are exciting [ __ ]
brands yes bread and circuses my friend
really is and ultimately let's say you
did Netflix and Disney plus seven bucks
and Netflix is 15 please says 21 this
still cheaper than cable was wasn't it
per month
I remember fan like a ridiculous amount
for cable where I'm like honey man watch
this anymore
yeah no cables like 80 bucks a month so
I still got a few more apps to go before
I'm back at my cable bill mm-hmm you're
gonna get on you're gonna need the
Warner Brothers app you give me whatever
that is my fancy [ __ ] I want that man
especially if they could stop DC
Universe which I hope they don't do but
like yeah man I would get I would get a
Warner Brothers app and then Apple TV
plus that's right they they [ __ ]
announced as well yeah with JJ and
Spielberg and Oprah everybody gets a
dream everybody don't get a show me and
you like it still talking about other
people [ __ ] got there's so many [ __ ]
places to get a show and why we should
just really try this year okay sit
around and go like there's a better
world where we have a show but we don't
really do much about it we should do
that yeah we should try ourselves into
it why not
[ __ ] they're giving away shows and we
should go fast because what's gonna
happen is like sooner or later they're
gonna be like this doesn't work and
they're gonna stop giving away shows
this isn't sustainable yeah we got to
close up shop and start making cable
again and floppy disks and do that other
[ __ ] yeah what happened somebody needs
to go they want to tow both of them oh
[ __ ] oh okay Ward's want either torrents
upon
Thank You JC all right well [ __ ] man
[ __ ] me that's I just made me more
excited for the Disney but I didn't even
know the price that's interesting
yeah that is the we're coming for you
Netflix yeah I'm coming for you hard how
do you think now we always talk about
Netflix how do you think HBO feels in
all this are they scared of Disney Plus
I mean they have their own app already
HBO yeah which I got as well so like
they're they're probably a little bit
safer especially because they are now
part of the Warner Brothers AT&T
universe and they are being tasked with
increasing the amount of programming
that they do yeah their boss is like we
want more shows yes like HBO I get that
you've been like living in this awesome
little curated space of Saturday and
Sunday and maybe another day but you
need to have shows on every [ __ ] day
of the week because that's how networks
work that's good for guys like us cuz we
could never get into an HBO back in the
day man but now that they let go of
quality yes if it's about quality we
might be able to get in I know that's
like the beer goggles phrase reel
program what do you have they wake up
the next morning we got a show with the
clerk's guy [ __ ] what's it about
wow man we should go we should go to
they're like look all these they're all
gonna be at each other's [ __ ] throats
we should use that image somehow I'm not
saying we're like this we're not the
main players in the story I accept that
but you and I we could be like [ __ ]
you know Vladimir and Estragon or
something like that or [ __ ]
Rosencrantz and Guildenstern we can get
some side action going on while Hamlet's
happening over there
that's all I want I don't want the big
showers with a little side action man
wet my beak a little that's all well
slap and tickle you don't need to holy
that's it [ __ ] like ten years I'm like
when you say like oughta cut Swamp Thing
down to like ten episodes I'm like I
take that like that be amazed extend
more than I have right no I don't have
any episodes of [ __ ] Swamp Thing all
right what else we good as we all know
sorry there's one last little thing okay
I think I told you told everybody about
my love for a comic book called lone
wolf and cub yes oh this is sad news
this is amazing books that a lot of us
lone wolf and cub is in our DNA
if your storyteller a lot of us even if
you've never [ __ ] sat down and read
lone wolf and cub you have ingested
something that was fed by lone wolf and
cub yeah it was a 28 volume long manga
series following a XMR executioner named
it Ogami whose wife was killed brutally
and who was turned against by his Shogun
a feudal Japan by the way in case you
didn't know and so he goes on the road
with his son his like five year old son
died Goro on a quest for vengeance and
it takes them eighty seven hundred pages
to tell this story it is one of the
great serial works of the 20th century
Bar None and it's a man with a baby on
his back cutting people up totally it's
it's a Western and it's at its core
logan owes a lot too much something come
totally I'm not a lot many things do
many things do it was written by a
fellow named kazuo koike and drawn by a
guy named gazecki kojima kazuo koike
passed away over the weekend so just a
little that's sad but I got to stop for
one moment to just be like your
pronunciation is excellent you weren't
even reading that I was something I know
do it again look at me and say those
named Otis even got an earwig yeah like
where do you pull this information no
cuz you Ocoee key and I remember his
name because I was an Eisner judge once
in 2004 which is kind of an amazing
weekend down in San Diego in April of
reading every comic book that comes out
in any given year and there's like five
of us who we're all like here my
favorite shows what I love here's what I
don't like and there's a conference room
filled
with every comment Kristen published and
so getting to read stuff that I hadn't
read before and getting to ingest things
that I hadn't and getting to advocate
for things that I loved was was fabulous
and wonderful and and it made me love
comics even more hmm but we got to
choose who was in the Hall of Fame that
year either judges always get to say
well here's you know two or three people
that we'd like to have put in and here's
who and the among the judge Corps wants
to nominate somebody mm-hmm and I was
like that guy like [ __ ] kazuo koike
like kids she was amazing he did that he
did crying free man he did a lady snow
blood like if any one of those works
would qualify but to have all three of
them under your belt like this guy and
the other judges agreed and so we
thought he got a Hall of Fame and the
eisenerz that year and so that dude
passed away I never met him I don't know
how I would have beyond like comics but
uh but no the book is seminal and and he
passed away and so just a little poor
one out yeah a big big time give it up
what's the how do you pronounce it again
Kazuo cooky give it up for that guy and
that my friend so so like so crazy how
his mini epic or maxi epic which went
for so long like virally spread
throughout the culture where people
probably steal from it liberally without
even knowing the source material at this
point yeah yeah I mean I I and I found
it because Frank Miller was doing covers
well yes the blacks had put out an
Americanized version of it America is
just a reprint wasn't even Americanized
version he did all the covers for it and
I was so [ __ ] hot for Frank Miller
off of Dark Knight I was like oh [ __ ]
this is cool and then read it was like
oh [ __ ] this is cool it's even better
than the cover yeah yeah man what a
legend somebody who really I mean we
like this [ __ ] this [ __ ] where people
are like oh this is the line in the sand
that I draw and I stand for this and
we'll talk about it until we have to
fight that's that's our whole [ __ ]
shtick in life that's our world that's
the things we love and that guy was one
of the best practitioners of it indeed
in the field so he will be missed all
right man so that's it that's all the
news that's all the news my friend oh
the news give it up
mark you read the news somewhat
inaccurately but I read all right now we
come to the other part of the show man
the part of the show that that it allows
us to actually get to know the audience
we're gonna do the Q&A portion of the
show and as per usual if you ask a
question and the question is good enough
you're gonna win some swag first off
you're gonna win some 4dx tickets what
what courtesy of our good friend
beginning the good folks at 4dx if
you've never seen a movie in 40x look at
the picture on the ticket there's the
two people and they're [ __ ] like
that's what it feels like this graphic
is true man so that you're gonna get a
pair of tickets I would have to think
that Avengers endgame would be amazing
the best time for all to try if you've
never tried out 40 actually and get some
free [ __ ] tickets yes
Avengers three hours and one of these
vibrating seats you will come so hard
and Nate Gonzalez here did this awesome
print so our winners will be getting one
of these signed
prints by dark Nate himself man okay all
we ever ask is that the questions that
you throw at us are something that both
of us can answer don't say stuff like a
man [ __ ] what happens in J and saw Bob
reboot because I'll be mad if Mark tells
you but I don't know because I wasn't
part of his friends and family screening
well I so weird you say that cuz I
actually thought about calling you last
night but this is what this was my
thought process because I stand next to
you doing the show all the time I'm like
I gotta get it tighter before [ __ ]
[Music]
I mean this [ __ ] couldn't even
fight it is hard to love Shazam like so
what you think in the movie it's well
lit [ __ ] moved as it cording Lee it
should so yes you'll be ready to see it
very very soon once I get it to 145 then
I'll be ready to show I kid because I
love ok so we'll leave it up to JC
proprietor this here cantina to pick 5
question askers good stir are good sir
JC as previously mentioned was at
celebration before you hand that mic
over man give us a quick [ __ ] rundown
of what you saw when you were there JC
it it felt I've been to all the United
States celebrations and it was a total
return to what celebrations always were
which was all about the fans on that
best got a standing ovation Columbia
grand got a standing ovation so like all
the crap you hear about constant toxic
fandom all gone right and he was in real
and IRL as the kids say
nobody said in the audience going boom
rose like they were like yay everybody
was happy even the people who were
working like security and maybe it's
because it was in the Midwest they were
like I very much like your strange
costume thank you for attending the Star
Wars Celebration like they didn't even
know what they were there for but they
were happy to be there it was awesome
and the Mandalorian stuff is is give us
a little you get you see you saw the
presentation what was Favreau there for
the presentation they bring out cast
what they do it was allowed to shake no
you didn't sign nothing your face yeah
no they're 5,000 people there that
they'll never know it was me
Favreau and Dave Filoni both went up and
felow needed the first episode but they
kind of gave the impression that it was
kind of a team effort through the whole
hateful Oni for those who don't follow
this sort of thing is
like [ __ ] Star Wars brain trust God
yes Morgan on the animated series for
years he knows more about this [ __ ] than
maybe possibly even George Lucas himself
yeah I mean the knee [ __ ] keeps the
work going he's the guy who I talked to
for I think it was geeking out an
episode of geeking out that shall we do
that they MC at one point where we were
talking about Phantom Menace you know
and I was like a [ __ ] Phantom Menace
and [ __ ] and he goes give me five
minutes and I can I think I could turn
you around on you're thinking of that
movie and he [ __ ] did by the end of
it I was like that is a [ __ ] good
movie like which one did you see I want
to I want to see that cut in the movies
like the same [ __ ] movie you saw
watch it again thinking that next time
and I did and I was like [ __ ] so he's
like he's the [ __ ] Lucas whisperer
you know he couldn't leave the guy that
like heard it from Lucas and then
whispers it to the rest should have
whispered louder but yeah the
Mandalorians stuff I mean family show
footage they showed like a two-minute
sizzle but they also showed like the
first five or six minutes of the first
episode what yeah and it's I believe the
main character's name is actually the
mandalorian which you hear in your
that's kind of stupid until you realize
it's the man with no name it's Sergio
Leone's Clint Eastwood and it takes
place post Return of the Jedi so you
still have stormtroopers but they're
like mercenaries for hire and you still
have all the nostalgic stuff you want to
see but it's presented in like in a wild
wild west way because there's no like
what's money because the Empire is gone
the New Republic hasn't started like
what's money what's what's so this is
like a [ __ ] purge of Star Wars yes
it's just a lawless [ __ ] world and
it's it is a old western movie set in
the Star Wars universe it's it it just
looks so cool my only critique would be
it definitely looks like season 1
budgets like if you go back
watch Game of Thrones Season 1 now
you're like oh that looks kind of shitty
but season 2 season 3 so I think by
season 2 of the Mandalorian Disney's
just going to be like here's all the
money to make this look a little more
expensive
it still looks kind of small and TV but
it's all of the divisive nough said I I
think we'll be fixed
starting November 12th because
Mandalorian will launch with Disney Plus
so Disney Plus launches on November 12
November 12 and the mandalorian serious
is it all episodes at once they're gonna
do one a week I damn it I like one a
week though because it's like Game of
Thrones it keeps here if you're Disney
and you launch this on November 12 and
everybody's talking about Star Wars for
10 weeks
what's 10 weeks after November 12
December 20th the rise of Scott which is
the rise of Skywalker that happens every
time I say something correct in this
world yeah
did I win a lightsaber just happen oh my
god how insidiously brilliant so the
channel will pop oh but the app will
happen and then we'll be watching Star
Wars up until we go to the theaters to
say this see Star Wars the new Star Wars
and probably let's be honest on the app
channel they'll be showing us some
slight if I wanted to get everyone to
[ __ ] join up who didn't join up
already trailers we're gonna [ __ ]
show you [ __ ] that's only gonna be on
the app like that would make me sign up
like crazy and [ __ ] Wow Wow
God they got my money again alright man
that's pretty awesome anything else
happen at celebration did you were you
there for the trailer or no did you get
in because I was like the overflow room
toys with like three thousand people but
not in the room yeah did anybody get
left out of the trailer experience what
happened Oh tons of people really like
it was all a lottery like instead of
having people wait in line for three
days to see something when you
your badge it had a number on it
basically and you've registered for the
panel so you wanted to go to and you got
selected in a lottery system so there
were some people who didn't get to go to
any panels what yeah there are some go
to celebration and not celebrate
well not the big the Phantom Menace 20th
anniversary episode nine Mandalorian and
I don't know what the fourth one was Oh
galaxy's edge we're the four really big
panel said you had to go into a lottery
to get and so but there were more panels
than that yeah there were tons there
like if you can't get into galaxy's edge
why don't you come to the Lobot yeah he
wants to see you they did much repo
musical review they did they showed a
trailer for the save
final season of Clone Wars they're
bringing back I'll get the [ __ ] out
really which looks awesome and its stars
come like that was marked there and mark
was not there Peter Mayhew was there
Anthony Daniels was there Billy Dee
that was awesome too because you heard
the laugh and everybody was kind of like
Joker's in this movie - yeah this is the
greatest Star Wars movie of all time
they really are I'm gonna get paid twice
yeah they're course-correcting but like
the everybody exited stage JJ kathleen
kennedy trailer plays you hear the laugh
and then the red spotlight hit in
MacDermid and you just said play it
again in the Emperor voice I like the
place went crazy that's awesome
and then the other exciting thing is
celebration next year's in Anaheim oh
[ __ ]
as a real clothes man no next spring
we'll have one close to home I mean
that's kind of so wait that's insidious
too by having a close to Anaheim they're
like we'll make them all go to galaxy's
edge mm-hmm time you're like yeah
they're thinking of us alike that's all
they do is think about you I'm just and
how to [ __ ] separate you from every
[ __ ] dollar you have till I come live
in Star Wars as the owner of scum and
villainy Cantina I'm okay with 50000
Star Wars fans coming into Southern
California for a week and a half you
know it's okay when in California visit
scum and villainy cantina I read
something about galaxy's edge they have
a bar they'll have a bar not like this
but they've got a bar and I read
something about the turnover is like you
only get like 10 minutes mm-hmm like
because it's space and there's no seats
and you got to stand and [ __ ] so when
you get into their Cantina like you can
order booze and [ __ ] like that but in
ten minutes they're like are you gotta
go yeah it's just shots glass or
something and I'll give you a very small
glass drink that quick man the banthas
are coming single file
enjoy that $20 blue milk that has half
an ounce of alcohol in it because you
can't get shitty in Disneyland yeah
that's true man yes I think you're gonna
be okay [ __ ] Star Wars anymore man
like here gotta strip some of the [ __ ]
down when is this going away for may the
fourth uh yeah we're taking it all out
May first so there's like ten days ten
more days of Westeros being here in
Westeros and stuff yeah I had asked at
one point I was like this is [ __ ]
awesome when I first came in and saw two
Westerosi I was like this is you should
[ __ ] leave this up for like two
months and he's like I can't and I was
like why and he goes me the fort's
coming up if this wasn't a Star Wars bar
on may the fourth they crucify me I was
like you're mixing up all your [ __ ]
Jesus things bad
so by May the fourth in which it's if
you're watching at home that's the
[ __ ] night to be here when I'm you
opening 6 a.m.
that's the night to be here the morning
may the so may the fourth is on Saturday
this year Oh last May the fourth let's
open it to p.m. it's La a lot of people
don't have real jobs and there was a
hundred people in line to get in it too
so it's like well what if we did like a
binary sunrise happy hour so we're gonna
do from 6:00 a.m. until 10:00 a.m. happy
hour for the you know serious fans you
want to spend 20 hours so or a serious
alcoholic and then we're gonna do some
some Star Wars trivia then you gotta
close and squeegee off the floors from
vomit but yeah it's gonna be it's gonna
be crazy it is kind of like Mardi Gras
for this place like it's sort of like
that is the [ __ ] holiday that's this
and the opening of a Star Wars movie is
what this [ __ ] bar is like built on
and [ __ ] so the notion of may the fort
being here may the 4th is pretty is a
cool notion it should try to get here
yeah all right man so that's coming up
very soon and no reservations right did
you think about opening up on like
midnight made the third just open it you
know we're like 24 hours we are you
allowed to go there 2 to 6 we have to be
closed because of the law law or else I
would have six or one baby yeah oh yeah
and it begins all right we were gonna go
into Q&A we should go OK night now
you picked somebody out but we had to
ask jay-z about celebration hey man what
is your name my name is Bryce what is
Bryce Bryce yeah Bryce he's got the
first question tonight
hiya zoom good good sorry to keep the
Star Wars taste in your mouth we're
gonna keep it going
so obviously the chariot came out so I
just want to know from you guys both of
you what would your seven eight-nine
look like you know how would you go
about directing it Ryan any things like
that what would you change what would
you put in a new who would you kill who
would you keep alive things like that so
yeah all that it's a big one I know but
you got it yeah
right but number one that definitely
wins give it up for a man pup that's
gonna send us down a rabbit hole 79 I
like when 79 is the last two and the one
that's coming right so if I've got to do
the JJ movies instead I like what
they've done so far I don't know that I
would have done much different but the
one element that I I think I would have
breakin mine broke my neck to try to do
is get all three of them into one
picture
like to get on Luke and Leia not just
like there's one there and there's one
there and there's one there but like in
the same shot like let's let him hug and
[ __ ] like that like that's that's so
that's the only thing that I would
course-correct I know mark will probably
have like cool salient story points and
[ __ ] but like what I honestly have liked
what they've done I also wasn't one of
those people that was upset with last
Jedi I was like guys [ __ ] interesting
I never would have thought to do some of
his [ __ ] and stuff and good and bad and
then there were moments where I were
breathtaking where you're like holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] and seeing last Jedi was
one of the best times I had in a movie
theater like that year when I when I
when it came out so I I've enjoyed what
they've done but I and I'm not saying
this was a mistake they [ __ ] up it
just didn't happen and I'm sure they
thought they had time or whatever [ __ ]
but getting those three and even I'll
squeeze Chewie into it as well into one
shot we'll just watch this from the back
yeah it's like a dirty [ __ ] he's like
they're all together that would have
been that's the only thing I could say I
mean and in force awakens' I didn't I
wasn't not enough to be like you'd
[ __ ] ruin it but the big Rolly things
that Han and Chewie were running from in
space and whatnot on the ship when we
first met him that they didn't do much
for me and stuff but generally speed and
and in last Jedi I thought went remember
where they they were on the casino
planet and that whole scene would have
been better if Lando was in it [ __ ] cuz
then you're like [ __ ] Lando but at
one point when they got on those things
and rode away like still to this day I'm
like why weren't they [ __ ] tauntauns
like that would have been great
fanservice like this is where [ __ ]
Tontons come from and that we haven't
seen one
and they help him get away and at the
end they like hide inside they got that
[ __ ] open and [ __ ] but that's like
little [ __ ] like that but not enough to
be like give me the [ __ ] franchise I
would have ruined it for sure but those
little flourishes are easy to [ __ ]
point out from the outside when you like
what they're doing but you're just like
oh she had a if they could have just
done this and that's the only thing for
me putting the three our three heroes
together in one frame it would have been
the movie and we're not and nobody knows
if that's still like not possible
impossible you know what I'm saying like
they showed us a [ __ ] trailer carrie
fisher's in it yeah and so at this man
she's not a CG character so anything's
possible I know some people like wants
all those dead in those movies yeah but
that was movies up in history a [ __ ]
force ghost hangin out and [ __ ] so there
is a chance a world where you could get
them all together again
kind of for one shot so I'm you know
holding out hope cuz if anybody could
pull that [ __ ] off it's [ __ ] JJ that's
the only thing I would add I bet you
here comes an hour I don't actually
don't have that much I mean I think that
they and they they fall along the same
lines that yours do is that there's
there's a couple moments of force
awakens that are a little just too
[ __ ] like why are we here like I don't
need the Rollie pollie under the [ __ ]
sewers of the great of the [ __ ] that
they're flying that's not the Falcon and
I don't care that there were cool
moments and and [ __ ] but it was one of
the one of the only times in that movie
where I was like oh we haven't seen a
Star Wars movie in a long time and this
is what they're gonna do okay you know
and then go with the journey yeah I mean
I kind of wish that that the big thing
you were gonna deal with at the end of
that for a force awakens was not a star
killer base you know like does it need
to be another thing that we saw before
like I feel like this is the death or
star I think that similarly the casino
planet is a waste of time the the the
change that I the the big thing that I
wanted out of last Jedi especially in
the wake of a knowledge that Carrie had
passed away is that if if you know that
you're probably not going to have a for
a third movie and you're going to have
this badass female character go out in a
blaze of glory let
that'd be [ __ ] Princess Leia let that
be general Leia yes Lord during laura
dern who was great in the wrong stuff
but yeah i we talked about that yeah
well if you want to blaze of glory like
that's a perfect way that was the moment
for that character to go out yeah and I
think that that but again that's one of
those like from the sidelines like you
know you could have done and I'm sure
Ryan John's is like yeah you know what I
could have done [ __ ] yoga hosers and
I didn't they brought me the script and
I said yeah but that was I mean you know
there's got to be a story there if one
day I'm sure Ryan will be like willing
it's not like there's a deep dark
twisted history but I bet you he's like
look you don't think we all [ __ ]
thought of that here's why we couldn't
we just didn't have yeah what the pieces
weren't there or [ __ ] like you know
they wanted to save it till the next one
whatever [ __ ] but like there's got to be
a logical explanation because he's an
expert storyteller I can't imagine he
didn't think of that too and he might
have answered this somewhere online I'm
sure every once in a while
Ryan pops up online to like just like
throw very low-key shade at people that
like [ __ ] the last Jedi and he's just
like I love Star Wars fans so yeah I you
know I I like that movie but I would
have been yeah and then the other one
thing and I would bet dollars to donuts
that JJ undoes this but that idea like
as much as I like the idea that Rey is
not a Skywalker and I still don't
believe that she is I don't believe that
she's nobody either you know and so like
I'm just saying
oh yeah look I I mean I hope she's
something I wasn't like when cuz in that
moment last chat I wasn't there like him
man you're [ __ ] you from garbage
people man [ __ ] life you're nobody in
the store I've really loved when he was
just like you don't even matter to this
story like I thought that was some dark
[ __ ] [ __ ] to tell a human being yeah
like could you imagine just somebody
come [ __ ] coming into your family and
being like you're not even really a part
of this [ __ ] school
some [ __ ] hurtful [ __ ] so I loved it
as a device in that movie but it is very
easily undone for him so feel like you
think that was real
I was lying I'm the look at my mask you
know it's back total I get in a in a
Miles Morales kind of way that's lovely
yeah but this isn't that story yeah like
this is a story about this family I need
her to be related to otherwise like this
was the Skywalker saga like where has
there bless you as as they're saying now
but as it's always [ __ ] been it
started with Anakin Skywalker it moved
on to Luke Skywalker and it feels like
the third trilogy should be about a
Skywalker I'd be I'd be I'm not gonna
say I'd be disappointed if it wasn't red
but I'd be surprised if they didn't like
it then they'd be like you know what it
is [ __ ] right there but at the end of
the day is about a Skywalker
because kylo Ren is a Skywalker and all
those movies haven't been about him to
me oddly enough I see her as like she's
the co-worker this [ __ ] she's the lead
but all of these movies have been about
the redemption of the bad guy the entire
the entire prequel trilogy Noah is about
like he was a bad guy we're trying to
redeem through love of family I I hope
she redeems him with a lightsaber to the
dick he went so [ __ ] they were
buddies they were fighting back to back
and [ __ ] and then he's like let's kill
everybody Rey and it's like oh you
[ __ ] idiot no no now we can't be
[ __ ] friends and he you know he
almost killed his [ __ ] mom he killed
the you know what he's got to pay for
killing han Solo
I don't give a [ __ ] never mind this like
everyone should be redeemed no
punishment first redemption in the ghost
world
he comes back as a happy force ghost
where he's like [ __ ] worked out after
they killed me but like with good reason
he's a wild dog running around killing
his dad [ __ ] kylo Ren yeah I want Chewie
to kill him too yes that'll be really
satisfying it at the end of the day the
scene is just like Carlos redeemed he's
like you know what it was wrong to do
that [ __ ] he's like I'm back so my god
so I'm so glad I'm so sorry it awesome
and [ __ ] he drops and there's Chu and
he's like credits people like that's
what the saga is building to yes it's a
story of a pissed-off friend man
or they're like the post-credits scene
is that Chewie like stitching him back
up and healing up taking care of them
and then doing it again like he's gonna
kill him over and over and over because
wookies live for thousands of years
totally I can keep you alive there I was
good that was a great question man thank
ya what do we got next JC
does that move to kids do that that's
genius I'm stealing that hey hey what's
your name my name is Josh give it up for
Josh everybody Josh going second Josh
take it there Josh so I'm sure you've
been asked this a thousand times but
everybody's opinion changes over time if
you could pick one villain from any
comic series DC Marvel whatever it be
what would it be and who would you cast
in it it's a way to pick what am i
picking one villain from any comic book
series and who would you cast I can pick
a villain was there a movie or I'm just
picking them and I'm like and you are
Woody Harrelson well I mean it was like
well what do I do now I'm like that's it
that's it nothing that's all I was asked
to do or is it for a movie like that it
would be for a movie whatever like venom
like whatever building coincide with all
right you go first I want first off it's
not fair
you'll go first who's my favorite Marvel
villain I'm not even my favorite but who
would make a great I mean Doctor Doom
deserves his own [ __ ] movie for sure
such a wonderful tragic story and Plus
maybe that's a great way like we always
start with the hero story maybe this
time around they start with the [ __ ]
villain story and at the end of it
[ __ ] he is the hero of this story
like look Marvel artfully told the story
with Avengers infinity war in which the
hero was a [ __ ] bad guy like the most
compelling character whose agenda was
horrifying but at the same time he like
I get why he thinks it's saying like you
know but [ __ ] that would kill a lot
of people so I bet you they could pull
off a story where Doom is the hero or
the antihero and the [ __ ] third act
like he gets foiled by the villains who
are [ __ ] the Fantastic Four and then
you meet your hero team and go on from
that so I would say if I was picking the
Marvel villain I mean you know I didn't
give it a lot of thought but I I would I
would say Mysterio but they're doing it
already but you could get a [ __ ] full
rich movie out of Doctor Doom I'm also
gonna go Marvel I'm gonna go name I
thought we had to go Marvel do we have
to go Marvel anything any VCR marble
alright hold on let me give you a few
more Marvel your Marvel my marbles Namor
he said villain he is a villain he is it
started as a villain yes
tricky somebody's not stoned on 4/20
somebody's just waving the fumes away
that's a good idea man anymore because
again it's a it's a it's a villain whose
story you understand yeah I don't get to
you get to follow his path towards the
light side of the ocean and more
importantly we've now established those
ocean movies like Aquaman proved that
like people will watch undersea stories
totally and I think it's tempting to go
the rock it's always tempting to go the
rock but I'm instead gonna go Stephen
young oh isn't it more yeah interesting
do you have to add some muscle I didn't
cast my Doctor Doom oh okay we should
have hit yourself
I love it yeah absolutely but he's he's
black Superman he can't he can't be he
could do it all
yeah man he'd be a compelling [ __ ]
villain he made that Star Trek villain
work and he was buried under a [ __ ]
bunch of makeup and [ __ ] yeah
so and he's pretty like cuz the super 8
Doctor Doom Victor Von Doom is [ __ ]
pretty like one of my favorite I think
we've talked about many times when I'm
favorite stories involving Doctor Doom
is when they took off his mask and you
know he was like I'm [ __ ] disfigured
I'm a horrible mess under here and he
has one tiny scratch on his cheek and
he's so [ __ ] vain that he threw
himself into this iron mask for his
entire [ __ ] life because he's like I
am not perfect that says so much about
that [ __ ] character man like at the
end of the day rips off his mask he's
not [ __ ] disfigured and [ __ ] that
means not only is he vain he's [ __ ]
psychotic as well so you get to tell a
good story they did that with Thanos
vane and [ __ ] psychotic man I think
they could do it with with doom and I
bet you Idris be a great one all right
so we got his marvel
there's Marvel DC I mean it's been done
but I want to see it done for in a real
world Victor freeze mr. freeze let's
let's see that story writ large and not
with Arnold Schwarzenegger being like I
study you like do Paul Dini
version from the animated series the
really tragic [ __ ] villains story and
whatnot which Batman is a and it's Idris
Elba playing mr. freeze don't be silly
Idris Elba is my Batman in this movie
Batman it could come in and play you
know minor parts but he's not the [ __ ]
you know hero of the story it's [ __ ]
freeze who would play mr. freeze who Oh
Sam Rockwell I like it yeah I'd be kind
of only if he dances yes and he could
dance before he goes that's the thing
like you know Sam Rockwell and so before
he's before he goes mr. freeze he could
be Sam Rockwell then when he got when
Nora you know is put under when he gets
[ __ ] hip out again then he loses all
that so he's suddenly Sam Rockwell is
giving this cold dead perform
an actor you know to be kind of vibrant
and she'll like that that would be
affecting without even really trying
suddenly it's just like you've just
drained him of what makes him him and
that would be compelling in that
performance who do you go
I'm gonna go Ra's al Ghul we've seen
that do we have to have not seen them
before and you did because you picked
Victor freeze that's true
my bad
[Music]
oh my god did you hear the white
privilege is doing at me I'm like we've
seen that and you're like we saw yours
too I'm like well but that's different
but that's mine I say who I say Wayne
fair enough Ra's al Ghul Ra's al Ghul I
think I want to deep cut and it's a deep
Star Trek cut but Alexander siddig who
played Bashir on Deep Space nine
most recently the Prince of Dorne on
Game of Thrones he was the
wheelchair-bound Prince of Dorne oh yeah
but he's an Egyptian actor who's like
[ __ ] classically trained who can
absolutely bring the heat I think he'd
be really interesting as the he's kind
of like a fan oohs - he's a fan those of
one planet where he's just like we got
to wipeout people here never mind
[ __ ] the galaxy yes like it needs
balance detective all right so we've got
those universes covered should we do
Star Wars only got one bad guy and they
keep using them all the time
have you met this Emperor fella yeah
he's back I can't I guess those are the
big two right yeah yeah that'll be
enough that was a fantastic question you
win a poser it's big you think I give it
up for him excellent job jack hi JC take
us someplace else
table represent what's your name my
friend hi I'm Mike everyone remember
Mike so my question for both of you is
when Disney redid our chair to become
guardians of the galaxy the ash James
going to come and help we even talked
about that but yes yes yeah for those
who are alive I don't follow this sort
of thing closely but how could you not
if you're watching this show you must
know by now James Gunn who was
unceremoniously dumped as being director
of gardens of galaxy 3 recently Disney
reinstated him and show they were like
hey man he's back we're doing it again
and and which is fantastic but this is
what a classy guy James is he could have
easily been like as he was working on
Suicide Squad as soon as they were like
here your toys back he could have been
like all right well I'm sorry guys I'm
back - guardians of galaxy but he's
still [ __ ] making Suicide Squad and
then he'll go to guardians of the galaxy
so he didn't even flat leave his new
friends and [ __ ] like that I thought
was very classy was very classy plus
we're getting two [ __ ] different
universe movies he's the director that
walks between two worlds at this point
you know what I'm saying like he'll have
Donna DC I know he's done many Marvel's
and he gets paid twice yeah but yeah so
anyway James gone back on guardians so
my question to you is a theme-park
needs some help they want both you guys
to collaborate and any IP what's your
theme park ride just a ride that number
one great [ __ ] question thank you um
you're gonna win give it up for him he
gets a poster take it alright so when I
was a kid and I may still be the same
way but I don't know there's like a
theme park a small one I think maybe
where was it I forget but it called
Kings Dominion and they had
hanna-barbera characters so like you
know everyone knew Disneyland and Disney
World and [ __ ] but Kings Dominion had
like hey it's the hair bear Bunch and
[ __ ] you really oh my god and I remember
that as a kid vividly but I've never
seen a theme park like since then we're
there well I guess Knott's Berry Farm
when Snoopy at one point like suddenly
they were like this is [ __ ] Snoopy's
home was it like that from the beginning
it wasn't no right it was like in the
beginning it was like taffy and [ __ ]
apples it's got poison berries yeah and
then one day they were like nobody wants
this [ __ ] bring in Snoopy you know so I
don't I don't it's and then great
adventure where Six Flags had the Warner
Brothers characters for a long time do
they yeah like as Magic Mountain up and
yeah yeah it's they use the Warner Bros
character every time for a while it was
that creepy thin thin thin thin turn
Michigan J frog yes
no that bald guy the weird all right so
I got theme park and I got a ride and it
could be any IP I want it to be alright
Jay and Silent Bob's [ __ ] smoker what
the ride does is up to your imagination
oh boy that name that would have him
lining up you I I kind of I've ridden
it's a small world enough times to hate
it's a small world
mm-hm but I think that if you took all
of the it's a small world [ __ ] out and
you left the [ __ ] boat and you left
like some a necrotic [ __ ] if you needed
to you could totally do a a willy wonka
ride on that [ __ ] trippy boat and
you're on like you're in there like we
have no way of knowing whether we're
gonna stop going yeah but like yeah and
you just like [ __ ] pumping like some
mist of like PCP in there like just just
a little just enough it's just a little
taste
sushant of the good juice it only lasts
for the ride yeah wears off yeah I think
yeah and then there's candy at the end I
like yours better than mine but you make
money I'm gonna add I'm gonna add weed
to my ride
I didn't know we could do that we can do
anything man it's true all right there
you go
all right thank you great question give
it up plum that was a great question all
right who we got next what's your name
my friend Steven everyone give it up for
Steve ed so real quick I guess it was
whispers in the Wayne I don't know if
it's Annie if there's any truth but I
heard Ezra Miller was talking with Grant
Gustin about the flash script Grant
Morrison yeah yeah I'm gonna be in a
flash movie are you are you sure yeah
but what I wanted to know what my
question is if they gave you guys the
reins how would you write it what would
you do would you continue with the
universe or would you do your own origin
story I've given flash I would do what
their towns like they're getting ready
to do which is [ __ ] flashpoint
flashpoint like the greatest flash story
ever [ __ ] told and if you're gonna
introduce people to the character beyond
like the TV show which most people are
very familiar with the character now
from the TV show but let's say there are
people that don't watch the show and
they're like oh I'll go to a movie or
something like that it's a great entry
point you know cuz the hero is just like
he's [ __ ] superfast and when they've
got the show they've got 22 episodes a
season to tell you 22 different stories
and stuff you got a movie you only get
would tell one story and that story is
predicated on he's really [ __ ] fast
so you have to do something that uses
that speed time-travel is definitely it
and that story is so wonderfully
compelling and anybody can identify it
but even if you're like not a runner or
athletic at all you can identify with
wanting to undo the death of a loved one
or something like that so I would I
would do that and I think that's what
they've been talking about doing they'd
be foolish not to begin with that one
same way that like Aquaman began with
like every Aquaman [ __ ] story they
could ever tell you in one move
we look at all the Aquaman you know just
in case they never got to do it again
and now they're being rewarded with like
people made it gave it a billion dollars
and so they're gonna get to do it again
they should do the same thing with the
flash and honestly they should do the
same thing with every [ __ ] movie they
ever make leave it all on the [ __ ]
table
don't world build and be like well we'll
save this for something else just
[ __ ] like spend it like you never get
to do it again because you don't know if
you do get to do it again and [ __ ] like
that that's what I got out of Aquaman I
was like they're literally putting in
everything and the kitchen sink and a
[ __ ] drum playing octopus because
they're not sure if they'll ever get to
do this again man it's like [ __ ] it
let's put it all in and it paid off like
it panned out and stuff so I think they
should do that you if they give me the
keys to the to the flash movie and if
they give me the money they were gonna
make the flash movie with I would not
make a flash movie because honestly I've
had four years of a TV show that I like
quite a bit like 5x5 like all of the
flesh each that I've had has been
scratched and then some like I think if
you're gonna do it flash point for sure
but instead like make a [ __ ] demon
movie like yeah yes adjacent blood yeah
like oh [ __ ] what a good idea like dude
let's go pitch that [ __ ] tomorrow hey
God you could do that cheap like look at
what they got in their hands at the
Joker now remember they announced a joke
and everyone's like go [ __ ] yourself and
then the trailer came out and everyone's
like I never knew I wanted this movie
and now people look forward to in [ __ ]
the budget of that movie 50 million
bucks give us 25 30 million dollar demon
movie just try to [ __ ] out you don't
have to [ __ ] spend half a billion
dollars to be like let's turn it into a
franchise roll the dice on [ __ ] Jason
blood like anyone outside of comics
maybe never heard of this [ __ ] guy
but it's a compelling cool [ __ ]
character of the great [ __ ] look and
it brings in hell he'll always sells man
yeah like I just I I don't necessarily
feel the need to hold on to the Justice
League universe and this only feels like
it's a bit of had like a last remainder
of a thing that we've already gone to
the well on like give me something new I
don't need to see that again and I see
it every week if I want it
fair enough but those weren't the rules
he said like flash so what would you do
I would just did two hours of the
[ __ ] race between em is you've
managed you see where they go and
there's a buddy comedy travelogue you
never take I buy I would like to pay you
cash money for this book etcetera I was
a great question man give it up for me
gets the tickets he gets the most well
done alright last one last one who's
gonna go to JC hello hi how are you
gluten-free vegan and non-gmo cut my
cakes these who gave these you these are
adorable so are they they're vegan
cookies that look and there it looks
like weed but it's not weed right why'd
you bring it no thank you oh my god is
amazing I'm gonna eat this on the way
home thank you if it says vegan I can
eat it
how are you what's your name I'm good
I'm Julie everyone give it up for Julie
proof positive that women come to the
show as well I actually came without my
husband to get out of here was it like
coming by yourself is it a fun
experience yeah Oliveira Street for the
blessing and the animals then I came up
here and it was really great were they
doing the blessing of the animals down
the Jill Oh
super cute when I was a kid that was a
big thing in our parish man blessing the
animals and the food like I'd its Holy
Saturday
brunch when I was a kid so let me say
I'm 48 now so like let's say 40 years
ago in the streams of time as an
eight-year-old I'm forced with my family
to go to church on a Saturday where I
remember being a kid and be like we have
to go to this [ __ ] tomorrow like why
are we coming now
to get [ __ ] blessed and my grandmother
would make a cream cheese lamb so you
take cream cheese and [ __ ] shape a
lamb out of it and [ __ ] and hard-boiled
eggs and [ __ ] and they put it all up on
the altar and then a priest came out
with a [ __ ] bucket full of holy water
and [ __ ] and would say this fast ass
[ __ ] prayer and then whip water on
all the [ __ ] food and [ __ ] like that
my god that has nothing to do with
anything we're talking about here but
when you said that I was like oh [ __ ]
like I haven't thought about that in the
[ __ ] long time other than the license
you give a dude in a robe did you soak
your food yeah and dirty water - I mean
blessed but dirty you know
in any event why right on man well nice
welcome all are welcome Russell over
children okay thanks
okay so while you were off shooting
movie I was listening the Q&A that mark
barnard and did in your stead
which I always love when you do those
it's nice to just have a little
something but I was saying it's nice to
have Kevin not around when I'm at work
so I know he's good so it's excited when
you were talking about Warren Ellis and
the works Warren Ellis and I you kind of
answer this in some ways in the last
question but I'm big fan of trains
metropolitan I'm shocked that there has
not been a trans metropolitan Oh show
pitched at this point because it's so
appropriate to our times right now my
question is what influential but really
obscure to non comic-book fans IP would
you pitch it's a TV show if you had an
opportunity to do a TV show like you
were saying go get that HBO money from
comics or non comics from comics but
sometimes Marvel or DC something that's
obscure but really influential like when
I was a comics fan the 90
things like trans metropolitan dawn
hitman these are things that were
incredible everyone who these things
were but now when I talk to modern comic
book fans it it's like they don't even
know what I'm talking about yeah it
makes me feel old whenever I'd mentioned
like grim Jack to somebody I'm alone I
got very excited before as you mentioned
was the first comic yeah first comics
did this book called grim Jack still one
of my favorite comic books of all time
John gaunt was the hero it's appropriate
to talk about it here because most of it
took place in a bar called monde ins in
a city called cynosure cynosure is a
city that phases in with every other
city in the entire [ __ ] world I think
I've actually read that from time to
time
it's like periodically it just meant
that like that story could happen in our
world like it could have clicked if
David did crossover could have clicked
into Gotham and cynosure would be part
of Gotham for a little while so the hero
of the story was a guy named John gaunt
Grimm Jack and he was the bar owner and
[ __ ] but he was like a Jeb mercenary
jack-of-all-trades the guy who gets [ __ ]
done solve [ __ ] one night and at one
point he got spoilers he gets killed
like and they killed him off and he dies
and he literally [ __ ] goes to heaven
in the middle of the run and [ __ ] and
you were like what are they gonna do and
then somebody reanimated his corpse and
started going around and killing people
and [ __ ] including all of his old
friends so he was in the afterlife in
heaven and he was like I can't let this
happen to my friends and so he chose to
come back to earth and be John gaunt
again but he had to take somebody else's
body because John gaunt was [ __ ]
destroyed he was zombified and stuff so
he took a new form and then came back
and had to convince all his friends that
he was really Grimm Jack Jack had a
[ __ ] scar in his face his whole life
so they're like you're clearly not John
gaunt he was like smash cut it into his
face they were like you are John gone so
all I need was your license man I loved
that book so much it was written by John
Ostrander who created the Suicide Squad
for DC I stole that [ __ ] I'm gonna
leave heaven to save my friends for my
Green Arrow run so that's what all he
does all he was in [ __ ] heaven and
then at one point he's just like he's
given this choice to like you could stay
here and you've earned your reward and
[ __ ] but down below this is happening
you have to merge and [ __ ] I stole that
right from
[ __ ] grim jack that's how much I love
that [ __ ] book so I would say grim
Jack it's a book that like anybody could
kind of get into but it's forgotten in
the sands of time for whatever reason
and that would make an excellent TV show
because every week for Tomb you're
snapping into someplace different you'd
never get [ __ ] bored cynosure changes
constantly so I would go for grim Jack
he had a little powell the bob who was
like a little lizard dragon kind of
thing who got drunk and smokes
cigarettes all the time this is starting
to sound very familiar to me and I would
totally watch the show right nice
sticking with the Warren Ellis theme
mm-hmm I would I would do an authority
TV show
I think authority was the the book in
the in like the late 90s that that
actually shifted the medium a little bit
and that comics for a long time in the
90s was like awful but the the work that
Brian hitch did specifically on
authority is the is him to refining his
palette that he would then bring to the
ultimates that would enlarge the
ultimate universe that would then give
us everything like that the whole idea
of like widescreen comics that these
were just we're gonna show you
explosions that are a spread wide and
it's all action and it's all fun and
it's all pace and it's all it's it's
it's pulp like comics when they're at
their best they're pulp and so an
authority is like big giant superhero
analogues so you get like a midnight or
an Apollo which like Superman and Batman
but they're also gay and totally in love
and then you get like the engineer who's
like Tony Stark meets Forge and she
invents [ __ ] and then you get Jenny
sparks who is just you're like giant
[ __ ] British saucy hero who's amazing
and you get villains like you know like
foo Manchu kind of analogues and it's it
is just this big swirly love letter to
all of kind of comic genre and tropes
and and and and archetypes wrapped up
and kind of like the Warren Ellis just
we're gonna crack wise and there's gonna
be five or six super cool moments at
every book and you're kind of gonna love
these people and so yeah thority I think
would be a great show I might have one
more to it give it up for Mark that was
very good
Matt Wagner made a great series when I
was a kid called mage the hero
Discoverer I love me so much
you have no idea one of my favorites
it's an amazing story it's it's Matt
Wagner is absolute best and you're
talking about a guy who also gave us
Grendel hunter rose and [ __ ] like this
he's absolute legend in the field that
story line is very simply put for those
that don't know it an update on the
Arthurian legend kevin matchstick slowly
discovers that he is the Pendragon I
mean there's a lady in the lake who's a
sword bearer I'm gonna get fun I'm gonna
[ __ ] cry talking about it it is such
an amazing [ __ ] story and it's back
in the 90s me and Scott Mosier like took
it out with Matt and and these other
producers to try to get it set up and
almost had it set up at Miramax at one
point [ __ ] but they always looked for
something a little more traditional like
Bob Weinstein was a guy who worked on
the crow like he had he didn't work on
the crow the crow was being made and
then you know paramount I think was
financing it and then Brandon Lee was
killed sadly and then they didn't want
to put it out and then dimension bought
the movie and put it out and then the
crow did like 50 million bucks which at
that point was [ __ ] huge particularly
coming out of dimension million dollars
somebody checked that but but it did
very well and so Bob Weinstein at that
point was always like I know comic books
and so we would come in with with [ __ ]
that was a little off the beaten path we
came in with mage we also came in with
preacher and Bob's thing on both of
those books was I didn't get this The
Crow I get the crow makes sense who's
the good guy in this he's the bad guy
I don't get this so we could never boil
it down to a simple goodbye good guy bad
guy formula even though mage pretty
straightforward and [ __ ] but for that
for that reason also maybe they were
like you can't handle this you made
[ __ ] chasing Amy for whatever reason
we couldn't move the ball forward but
man
in the mid-to-late 90s I was trying like
mad to get mage made it might be time
again somebody with talent should get it
done
I'm just alright that this was back at a
time where like nobody was doing that
[ __ ] like now throw rock somebody's got
a every comic book property is [ __ ]
spoken for every piece of IP is being
snapped up Golden Age for creators and
stuff because of you know the Marvel
stuff and the DC movies
everybody's like comic books man it's
the new Western so everybody's happy to
have a piece of the game so there are
plenty of people to get the [ __ ] made
now back in the 90s nobody cared about
it so I was like waving a flag on you
got to read this like this would make a
great movie this would be a great movie
now you've got plenty of people knowing
that that shit's great there you can't
even find IP that's up for grabs at this
point people snatch it up so [ __ ]
quickly so I would imagine there's
somebody out there working on a [ __ ]
mage movie right now and or sand god
there better be somebody working on a
[ __ ] grim Jack TV show gotta be right
but it ain't me it's for better people
than me I'll give you one more only
because I plugged it earlier is a lone
wolf and cub yeah I would I would love
to see the giant HBO version of that
show spend all the [ __ ] money
rebuild feudal Japan like get an
entirely Asian cast just [ __ ] go to
town because where would you put white
people anyway yeah like you can that
that show could go on for literally
eighty years ten ten ten episodes a year
there's thirty [ __ ] books yeah
thirty years never run out of material
never see excellent question which
yielded wonderful responses give it up
for a lazy way alright wait let's talk
about this man before we get out of here
who's give somebody a mic and let
somebody go up to the wall in this the
game that I don't get to play it says
hey Kevin mark this is our crazy sci-fi
board game secret unknown stuff escape
from Dulce don't know I'm sorry Dulce
it's pretty oh they phonetically spelled
team of aliens mutants and abducted
humans escaping an underground base to
stop an alien invasion from the moon oh
that's hot
inspired by comics and D&D and films
like buckaroo banzai you have my
attention and star wars one copy is for
you and one is for a lucky audience
member of your choice they just have to
answer this trivia question go to the
second box I didn't realize there was a
part to hold on to this year quit you
know there are two guys in that group
sometimes
here's the trivia question okay I'm
first off sentient cow games yes is that
you guys yes to gather in under the ran
or three can see you stand together get
cozy
no together together three three best
friends nice Greg Donna and Weller okay
yeah and what's the story
so the story is we were started as
neighbors
Weller was a big comedy into the light
or off they can see everybody's got
squeezed tight cuz the camera only
captures the serious picture yes we
started as neighbors we shared a
backyard with our pets and we'd have
beers and talk about comic books and
punk music and video games and they work
for a toy company brought out from
Philly
I'm a comic book writer and a
screenwriter and one night we're like we
should make a board game and she
kick-started so a year ago we raised
about 80k and we launched the first in a
trilogy of sci-fi dungeon crawls so you
escaped from Dulce which is Dulce New
Mexico which is like a lesser known area
51 conspiracy so in five miles north of
Dulce New Mexico there's an underground
base in the Archuleta Meza or supposedly
gray aliens have made a deal with the
government to abduct citizens in
exchange for technology and they do
terrible experiments so use this the
game or is this real [ __ ] this is
because that was some impelling
storytelling well they have yes so what
did we get it's both but you start out
is you can play as a two-headed mutant
cow with machine gun strapped to its
back or a millionaire heart or 500 year
old feudal samurai abducted from Japan
back in the day and you're trying to
escape a 3d board like Dungeons &
Dragons so you gain experience points
gain items and you work your way to
freedom now this is the first in a
trilogy of games so we escaped from
Dulce so secret unknown stuff secret
don't let me move I'm animated so secret
unknown stuff is our universe like Star
Wars a new hope right so the first ones
secret unknown stuff escaped from Dulce
right secret unknown stuff the hollow
moon so after this one you can take the
same characters on board to the next
adventure to blow up the moon to stop an
alien invasion that's cool man that's
really cool and the third one's called
lost in time so you have to stop
yourselves from blowing up the moon it
goes a bad choice blood of the Moon and
so after you spent the whole second game
blow of the Moon yeah alright so here we
go for somebody's gonna walk away and
what's this on top is this part of it
extra stuff a trivia question and how do
we pick somebody to answer it the hands
whoever's hand you scan the room I'll
read the question whoever hand goes up
first okay I got this side well you
gotta have all the sides cuz I'm reading
the question here we go
the question is the quote on our box
cover good luck you're gonna need it was
said by what character - what character
and in what movie this guy has a thought
do - I see one right there - who
that is correct the ideas here on solo
to know whose hold on one more 10
there's no microphone han to Lando ever
to the Jedi and the answer is correct he
wins the game that is correct
he'd better give it up for him ladies
gentlemen whoo yeah the guy who just
came from Star Wars Celebration has some
insight into Star Wars movie thank you
I'm caught up here all right man is
awesome so I get to take this one home
and not play it with Mark share I will
have mark yeah just just text me be like
hey man this is really fun you should
come over psyched
[Laughter]
I think that's covered everywhere thing
I also have another show after this what
time is it
it is now 6:05 I have a show at The
Improv at 8 o'clock Hollywood babble-on
so I got to wrap up man but we have been
here for quite some time I've been here
for two and a half hours it's a long we
had a lot of ground to cover
it's been one minute since we've been
here man I had a [ __ ] blast
ladies and gentlemen did you guys have a
good time I can't thank you enough for
being here man but there is no [ __ ]
fat man be on without the guys stand-in
here give it up for the great Marc but
ardent ladies and gentlemen and that
from the scum and villainy Cantina is
fat man beyond for this week I'm Kevin
Smith I am mark barnard and tune in next
week same fad time same fat channel
SModcast calm or youtube.com slash Kevin
Smith happy 4/20 everybody good
[Applause]